coming to you in
five
four
three
two
welcome welcome everybody
it is the h3 podcast back in quarantine
we have the council of ricks
joining us here from home
a.b zach cam
love
ian and special appearance from olivia
are you playing hooky today olivia
what's going on
uh no i got out of class earlier and ian
texted me and said it was all on zoom so
excited to be here olivia
olivia please stand up
stand up i've been listening to olivia
we've been listening to you the entire
time
today's episode is sponsored by mint
mobile honey and liquid iv
dan is here with me braving uh
risk of
permanent death that's right
thank you anything for the show
you notice that
i've uh ascended i've reached apotheosis
i've transcended how so i'm controlling
ian's computer switching from the
scorpion chair i've got
zach's uh sound uh mixer over here wow
i'm doing zoom on this screen oh you're
in the matrix i'm in the matrix i'm
fully fired yep
that's right yeah
dan is taking over they don't who played
that sound bite was it your zack
that was me okay
dropping the uh the monsieurs from home
we love that for you
yeah uh did i think the sponsor's
already you did
i did
just do it again i don't even remember
you did you said this episode's brought
to you by but and mint mobile honey and
liquid iv did i say those three already
i don't think i did i think you did
unless you got distracted halfway i
think i got distracted okay well it's a
good thing we did it council of ricks do
you guys recall me reading those
i do not recall okay i do not okay thank
you council of ricks dan they have
spoken out against you
that's okay i love the council it's
awesome
so today's a special episode actually
we have unearthed
like an egyptian tomb
a keemstar and fouseytube collaboration
that is so foul it's like you know when
you open king tut's tomb you get a curse
it's like that
so everyone watching today is
i'll take the curse
you guys won't be cursed i'm taking it
for you so that you can just enjoy wow
actually you know what i prefer heat
actually you know what i think ian
should take the curse
that seems fair i don't want that curse
somebody's got a little nothing fair i
gotta lead the show
i mean council agrees
yeah ian's taking the curse
i'll i'll pass along to somebody
well the curse of being a kanye fan is
is uh runs deep enough doesn't it
thoughts we already hitting thoughts
already
early i did see you were listening to
donda too don't deny it
i was a photoshop that was not real
you got got no no no no no you were
listening
i was not listening the entire time wait
you didn't even listen to donda two
there wasn't really much to listen to i
don't know are we are we gonna
are we gonna yes talk about it
i mean we are talking about it are we
not you don't have to i mean i just
think
look it wasn't that long ago where
you're like i'm taking the day off i'm
going to the beach and i'm going to have
a i'm going to have a met be enter a
meditative state when every when kanye
drops music i mean you may not co-sign
the man but you still got to be excited
for the new album
can you believe that was like four years
ago no stop it
that was 2018.
you were so
no dude stop the incident you're talking
about where where he took a long drive
down pch was uh that was the previous
album okay yeah
that was yay
yeah yeah that's it it was 2018. it's
crazy
2018 that's four years dude multiple
multiple panel of ricks were
live messaging me the whole the whole
thing oh
well i'm just asking did you watch it
you're saying no
i saw some of it i checked in briefly
yeah okay to back him up he was having
dinner and he was like if anything crazy
happens let me know but he's really
changed i mean when dinner takes a
priority over the new kanye
pretty incredible so who's your favorite
artist right now have you replaced him
with somebody
i'm
taking a step back
from fandom just music in general
or fan yeah
yeah i gotta i gotta find someone new
right
i'm in the market you're looking okay
good let us know if you find someone
that'd be great
i just i care about you and i just want
to know what you're up to
[Music]
i'll let you know
there's so much shenanigans going on on
the panel right now
[Laughter]
uh i the panel is just and then cameron
is looking like james charles i mean
what the
what is happening
what are you talking about
oh well i see pete
oh you see olivia's taken aback by this
oh olivia all of a sudden getting a
little in getting looking at cameron new
for the first time here
i mean
love hasn't been able to do his you know
shenanigans on love boss so he's going
crazy right now
yeah for sure i'm getting it all out
right now yeah yeah i love giving up all
the energy love grew a killer goatee
that we're just all
taken aback by dude this is the craziest
zoom class of all time
uh well hello brandon brandon's here
hey jack
what the heck
um something for the ukraine
i mean i got kids with hairy legs and
they come jump on my lap
got hair delayed oh no oh joe oh joe
leave cam alone
what the hell these filters are so
absurd man that's just
that is just ins that is just ridiculous
i gotta say some uh behind the scenes
here love uh discovered all these
filters so they showed him this app here
so
so
so that's i'm assuming uh our president
sniffing your hair or something like
that right yeah he's kind of getting
keyed out back there but
oh my god
that that should be that should be a
crime
have a filter like that
what do you mean
what do you mean jack i like to smell
the hair
it smells good
nice little it's
for l'oreal every now and again don't
hurt nobody is it you know it's good for
your it's tasty for you you take a sniff
of the hair in the morning smells good
like a cup of coffee
all right i'll pause thank you well
what a carnival so there's a few things
we got to get to before we get into the
indiana jones version of keemstar cringe
it's a whole 40-minute
uh
festival
that apparently you guys previewed you
said it's so phenomenal
that i'm going in raw
yeah and you know i was i was having
second thoughts about this morning
because we were planning on spending a
lot of time on at the show and i'm like
what if you know we don't have a lot
planned today if ethan's not feeling it
like what else are we gonna do so i just
started watching the first couple
minutes again and
we might not get through the video
you're gonna be pausing a lot
10 hour episode baby
okay [ __ ] yeah but so unfortunately one
of us on the panel here
tested positive for kovid um
what was it two days ago one day ago
and so we immediately i went into
quarantine i've been in the basement
because obviously we have a newborn baby
and a son who's two and a half so
obviously neither of them can be
vaccinated
so i'm being very careful i don't want
to get any of them sick
and
what's the incubation time from exposure
to it can be up to almost two weeks
right i mean two weeks or ten days
well they're doing five days they keep
changing the guidelines at at one point
in time it was uh
well now they're making everything like
14 less severe so
can somebody actually look that up baby
because i actually need to know how long
i need the quarantine for 1 to 14 days
1
to 14 days i need a little clarity bro
i'm living in the basement
uh here whenever anybody tests positive
they get sent to the comfort inn and
they only stay for five days and then
they're putting the comfort in yeah
what do they gotta what does your school
have a collaboration with the comfort
inn what is that yeah i don't know it's
like my school has taken full monopoly
of the only hotel in uh i'm going to buy
a comfort inn near your your school and
clean up like a bandit that's right
they're probably like yeah yeah yeah uh
500 a night a normal rate
come from well i need to know how long
do i because
bruce has one kidney
he's young i do not want to get him sick
how long do i need to quarantine for
it seems like if you want to be extra
safe
14 days is no no no i'm not doing 14
days
14 pages either are you watching this
wait okay
i was gonna i was gonna do three i was
gonna do
maybe i should do five days
that's a comfort end i'm standard
peeping over at the chat and i do see
well the comfort inn has high standards
maybe i should go to the comfort inn
they're saying all kinds of things i i
fourteen ten five five also i think it
depends on it depends on the strain
well it's definitely the chronic
the omicron is less um so what's the
chronic
it's saying five to ten days i'm
thinking five
okay well we'll see we don't care just
keep testing ten days colleen ten would
probably be enough to get through eldon
ring by then you think i could beat it
in that amount of time
yeah if you watch ten straight days ten
straight days of play time yeah well
yeah i mean i got nothing else to do
there you go i just feel so bad for poor
ela she's she's gotta do everything
that is rough i mean her mom's there so
she's able to watch bruce oh that's good
but handling theodore one on one is a
daunting task
[Music]
it is rough but perfect excuse for you
to play the game i mean
take advantage of it
no but it is scary i don't want to i
don't want to expose bruce that could be
really dangerous for him people saying
poll we're not this is let's do a poll
are you serious yeah your son's health
you're going to leave it up to the chat
poll i just want to know what people
think because it's so it's just so
nebulous let's do three days
five days nobody's saying three days
[ __ ] nobody everyone says you said three
days
at no point today somebody tell ela
because she's gonna kill me
so
[Music]
i would say five days seven days ten
days then seven days
no 14
you can add 14 but don't you [ __ ]
vote for that
could make some great ethan klein video
in those days
i just feel like ela's gonna kill me
but what can i do i mean
okay so are these the days that it could
be like hidden wouldn't it like i'm not
sick yet it takes time for the for there
to be enough virus in me for the test
positive show up on yeah i see ac
because i took a test yesterday and this
morning both negative so
i'm going to keep taking one every day
i have a pcr test scheduled for
tomorrow
that's good all right got it
uh it's a so the fives are winning but
just barely over seven and then 10 and
then 14 in last place actually 10 and 14
are tied so
honestly it's
the vote is really tight between
somebody tell either because she she's
gonna kill me dude i mean yeah
hey i'm typing it hello
seven they're saying
five to fourteen days
yeah
i don't know just call like a doctor
yeah
i should totally write
i could ask a doctor yeah we got that
primo i'm gonna write the point i have a
pediatric doctor there you go yeah
actually you you have a top shot doctor
but explain i have a newborn baby he's
two weeks old and he has one functioning
kidney
okay
will do
thanks bro
no problem
okay so we thought we'd play a game
i didn't say who has coveted and some
people were taking bets we have well
obviously olivia's not even here
dan doesn't have covers he's here with
me
so you have five culprits five of them
a b
zack
cam
love and ian can we get some game show
uh music or something going zach do you
have access to that
okay that's exactly what i was looking
for
but but if we have a vibe though i don't
know
i love seeing all your faces at the same
time it's just it adds such a beautiful
layer it's just so entertaining
it's so nice
you can't hide from me anymore ian
can we should probably do the show like
this
well
when they come back we should have a
panel where you see everyone's faces
we'll see if we can figure out a way to
i think the people are gonna like this
all right so so
i don't know maybe uh how should we do
this maybe the chat i'll read off
questions from the chat we'll do a round
of questions
and then you guys can vote
to kill a person
because it's like uh among us
so you killed the person who's uh
sussy right
[Music]
you see everyone kick them out of the
airlock yes okay so we're gonna kick the
airlock out and then we have to see
uh so okay
guys in chat if you have any questions
for our five uh among us players
um people lots of
it's going very fast here oh man a lot
of people think it's a b
um seeing a lot of abs
when we did a poll on twitter lots of
people said av so av let me ask you a
question yes you have been around a lot
of people but training right
uh i want to say a lot but yeah i've
definitely probably been out more than
most of the crew and how many people are
you around when you go and train for the
boxing event
um i have one-on-one training with uh
my trainer and in the gym there's
probably about
i'd say about
15 other people wow
and heavy breathing right because it's a
physical activity yeah yeah everyone
wears a mess though everyone has to be
very needed and they check your
temperature when you walk in oh wow
that's actually really
reassuring well
so you wear a mask when you when you
spar
yes wow tonight man
dude you're gonna be impressed he's
going to be like piccolo where he like
takes off the weights and he's like a
real fight it's like training on everest
you know so you have super fun
love is really just he's redefining
water cooler talk he is the water cooler
yes he's having too much fun
okay so that that that's that's pretty
good that that actually answers a lot of
my questions maybe
other than that have you been outside
have you been around other people
no not really the only thing was we went
to catalina for alina's birthday but i
mean a lot of tourists and catalina a
lot of tourists was it island fell empty
no it felt the island felt empty
everyone's telling me we should have
came in summer
[Music]
zach what have you been up to have you
been out have you been around people
i go to work and come home
okay
love that nothing to you live with uh
your girlfriend what's she been up to
uh
well she's been quarantining with me
um
but she goes to work and comes on the
pool
okay
cameron what about you
last time i saw anyone outside of work
was on the 12th and it was just my
friend and their partner
your friend and their partner right
on the 12th
yeah i was well that was a while ago
but we did learn the incubation period
five to 14 days
you will sound a little nasally i'll say
your your voice your nose sounds maybe
congested a little bit
maybe i mean are you congested
a little bit maybe okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
love you living with cameron so this is
an interesting dynamic
and you guys kiss right or no
no we're not at that stage yet
and and how are you feeling have you
been out and about you're on a tourist
you're a tourist right now so i'm
assuming
i've been very careful
i'm super careful and i have these
in sweden we don't really believe in
kovid so
that prevents me from getting it
actually right
and i am super energetic
that that is true you definitely don't
appear to be sick i'll say that
yeah
okay
everyone thinks zack self-reported why
what did that what did zach say the
whole chat is saying me but what is that
you said you you said you've been
quarantining with your girlfriend well
since well we're all coordinating we're
all quarantined yeah that's not a
giveaway yeah they misunderstood we're
all quarantining
since we got the news
so ian is wrapped up in a blanket are
you cold yet um
yeah it's always cold in here but ian is
always cold we've learned that
previously yeah yes yes are you feeling
uh what have you been up to what are
your activities been
ah you know i'll go
i'll go get a sandwich oh
okay sandwich i'll go get a little of
this
oh
i might go get a little of that see he's
he seems a little spicy and if you
recall ian is the only one that has had
kobe before and
he got very delirious when he had kobit
last time he got bodied by the way is
your long coved settled yet
i think so yeah ian got hit by like the
alpha coveted and it actually got you
pretty good i remember
yeah it was it was rough i couldn't
taste for for a long time you feel your
taste buds are restored to
pre-covet
yeah probably like 90 95
that's good yeah yeah
so but but so when you go and get a
sandwich like are you going tell me
about that situation you go into a
crowded shop are you wearing a mask how
crowded is the shop what are we doing
i'm a masked you know i'd never dine in
i go home
okay
you know that's kind of it
um yeah and olivia we obviously know
that you're not the culprit but uh
not to leave you out
have you been to the motel the
comfort of comfort inn lately
i have not thankfully
i used to go over parents weekend though
but i don't think that they're renting
out
does like does crazy stuff go down at
the comfort end do people like get up to
shenanigans there
not
like the covid patients but i remember
the first time i stayed there um a guy
came out of his room with a an ankle
monitor on
nice
that's about what you'd expect from the
comfort inn
i was okay with it
at least he's being monitored i mean
right better than a criminal with no
ankle bracelet that you don't know who
it is
agreed
all right well you guys have basically
heard from all five possible
suspects so here's what we should do is
we'll take a poll
and the top person is getting thrown
into outer space to be to perish in an
agonizing death
[Music]
and uh
we'll take it from there so my problem
the poll only lets you have four uh
options at least the youtube poll does
oh crap i know
maybe effective cam and love should
count as one since they live together
okay that's fair i guess i mean it's
fair
all right i'm asking who got
by the rona
all right putting up the poll now all
right guys so make sure to get your
votes in
contentious here
zach says he's been up to nothing abs
been out and about
but very good standards at the bot at
the boxing place
cam has the sniffles
uh love is energetic he's clearly not
sick
ian is cold
okay this is really interesting
overwhelming
45 to zach and i actually don't know why
zach is getting all the
i don't get that one at all
can you guys can you can you guys
explain why you think it's zack i think
this is interesting i'm just a true part
of your man going out slamming beer it
is a joker brain situation though for
sure
joker kovic new strand um
okay well you guys have
unanimously voted zach so
drum roll
is it zach
have we found the imposter
no it is not zach
well you got to do the ant right and and
turn off his feed because he's dead now
bye guys
the [ __ ] out zach turn off sax feed
can you do that uh i just mute my video
just yeah just turn your video off
you're dead [ __ ] out empty seats sad
all right well well zack is is out in
the outer space good job guys
you killed an innocent man
[ __ ] hey you're dead bro
silence
okay up uh we have remaining we can add
cam and love separately now yeah uh we
have ian love cameron and maybe
i just uh threw it up everyone thinks
it's me because they're saying i look
distracted or i look like something's on
my mind
love is distracting the [ __ ] out of me
that's why i'm watching the love show
that's why he's literally running labs
but i'm whatever well i would i would i
if oh if i was in the audience i i might
suspect you only because your activities
yeah even though it's been very safe
well it looks like the audience agrees
because a b is getting blown out right
now on the vote
a b is 60
is it a b
no it is not a b
a b is being shot into outer space bye
dude they're back in space two innocent
man have died wow
you guys are just ruthless ruthless
unbelievable
three people left is the sussy boy
gonna win
ian love
and cameron
who has coveted
all right next pulls up
okay
so cast your votes now
[Music]
there's three options
love and cameron are pointing at each
other
ian in his blanket is
looking sick looking the part
love is flossing
okay
well this time you guys have voted ian
and i gotta say ian does got the blanket
we did make a clarifying statement he is
always cold
and he has had coveted ian do you have
do you have covid
no
i don't
outer space you idiot
you just killed another innocent man you
[ __ ] blew it bye bye loser
cam and love the two guys living
together
one of them has coveted
and one of them does not
[Music]
love is looking very active it could be
a ploy to
throw people off to throw people off it
would be pretty ironic for love to get
covered here on vacation
my man's doing push-ups there's cam who
i have noted has a stuffy nose
[Music]
get your votes in because this it's
close and this is this is the final vote
i just don't have enough space to do
push-ups over here
are you about to do push-ups
i would but i don't have enough space
love is doing push-ups
i was having trouble
understanding what i'm looking at to be
honest
all right
guys get it in it's 51-49 this is
important wow
go through cam guys it's close
don't don't rock the vote
yeah all right looks like we have a
definitive answer
cameron
do you have kovid
[Music]
i do
unfortunately
oh wow
so love wins and uh cameron
i'm sorry
that you caught covid
what's the important lesson
audience don't know [ __ ]
i tried to i said cam is sick i said he
has the stuff he knows yeah
i i don't even have a stuff he knows is
the thing too no you don't know
i thought i heard a stuff he knows i
just don't know why i was ousted so
quickly that i don't get that they
targeted you zack
so kim how are you feeling
i feel fine i mean today's the first day
i feel like actually sick sick but like
oh it's still getting worse
yeah but like
i feel fine obviously you know like i
just i'm more scared about spreading it
than actually having it
you know cam has been
having like an anxiety attack for the
last 24 hours about not about him being
sick but fearing that he got us sick
well i was just saying it's not your
fault bro like you said you were super
careful it's just this this chronic is
so uh contagious
i don't think you you you need to feel
bad about anything you you were careful
you're vaccinated you did everything
right
cameron is very nice and i don't know
how the hell love isn't sick that was
the thing too because i've been driving
him every day and like you know he's
he's testing things bro it's the nordic
jeans well he's a young man he's
vaccinated i mean the vaccine does work
or i mean like it does you know it helps
prevent you catching it yeah exactly
yeah
and he just
he just got an umbrella
yeah
i mean i've been locked up in my room
he's been uh delivering me
like water and stuff and gatorade that's
nice what a guy
yeah i got a bathroom i'm good i'm i'm
on house arrest right now but i'm happy
yeah actually because you're sick i
think you have to stay quarantined what
for like two or
until he tests negative
yeah
no not you
cameron i think it's like uh what i read
is like five days after the symptoms go
away too but like you know
that could take a while a little
vacation for cam yeah elden ring uh
and i don't even play video games so i
guess i gotta play hold on right now the
kill you know what do you mean what do
you mean you don't you don't play video
games not really really not as much as
i've been making you play video games
he's not a true gamer but i i don't
think you can say that you don't play
video games he's been playing fortnite
with us hey you've been playing fortnite
we were playing we were playing halo
dude you guys are such kids these guys
play fortnite together they're like
babies
yeah it's mostly a b that's pushing for
the fortnite thing
dude everyone's on it now loves you to
talk [ __ ] i'm talking [ __ ] like
yeah
that's epic dude you're talking [ __ ] on
fortnite so sick that's so cool dude you
guys gotta see my yo
i have the sickest [ __ ] emotes did
you tell a 12 year old you had sex with
his mom yet
[Laughter]
i usually go
never mind you know what
why don't i get invited to these games
because i don't game zach you have a
[ __ ] ps2
oh burn nice real good
when uh i i don't have a system i love
when we play [ __ ]
so what do you want me to invite you to
i could play
with your imagination you just said you
don't have the system
play with myself i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah you play with yourself i do play
with myself hold on there seems to be
some resentment that zack's not getting
invited but do you understand you don't
have the appropriate
hardware yeah you can't play on mac
no
[ __ ] me then yeah i have a mac i
actually just bought a pc because i'm so
sick of that stupid mac it just sucks
finally
well since you're epic gamer now abe do
you want this chair back
oh come on no not the chair
i'll take it i i offered him before the
show i'll use it in the office hand to
god ethan i don't i have no use for this
thing okay well you guys sorted off off
off off camera can't get back into the
chair nightmare
by the way i'm sure they'd love to play
with you zach if you just you know had
the whatever
it's okay i'm used to it
what do you mean that you think hold on
you can't play with that oh you wanna do
this exactly
into oblivion
zach will always be like hey dude we got
to hang out we got to hang out black is
the only one he was never down to hang
out yeah so cool he's so popular and
well he does live pretty far away in his
defense
he chose to live there
what what does that mean zack's played
one video game it's batman and that's
right oh and yeah he's committed to the
joke why don't you get why don't you get
a computer so you can hang with the guys
i mean
because i i just i've never really been
that big into video games and um
i'd rather honestly rather do other
stuff but if the offer is on the table i
will play fortnite with you guys
the offer is on the table okay it's been
on the table
yeah but like
he's going to understand
down a little bit yeah
what are you [ __ ] new you really want
to play with him i'm a [ __ ] noob well
if he hosts we'll be in easier lobby so
we're all there music we're in there
making kids throw their ipads like all
day because they're all playing [ __ ]
[ __ ] suck
like the kids we're playing against
they're so easy to kill you you get it
you get a headshot you like dude you
guys win battle royales oh yeah
really nonstop you guys are pretty good
then we're going to win
and we're like we know that kid just
screamed at his mom he just so bad he
just punched his keyboard
yeah seriously
that could be you zack okay well zach
you you do you do you retract your uh
complaint
kind of i guess
i'm so very
well would you be happy if they were
like begging they're like zach we need
you you need to buy a computer we need
you to join us if if a b got down on his
hands and knees maybe
but that's what you'd be satisfied with
extremely yeah yeah
av can we get a begging can we beg zach
hands and knees
um he gets on his knees first
but everyone's on their knees begging
each other
fellating each other potentially
then we can all be happy
yeah exactly all right we do have like a
10 hour keemstar documentary to get to
yeah but that was fun but cameron you're
okay you're feeling okay yeah i'm
perfectly fine i just you know slight
throat that's fine though i'll live
what were you feeling that made you
think oh i should do a test well i took
a test uh monday night
and it came back negative and then the
next morning it felt slightly worse i
was like i'll just take another test for
safety and that's when it came back
positive and i had a anxiety attack and
then i uh siren the group and then you
know and then uh here we are today but
what was the symptom you were feeling
like a sore throat mainly on monday i
had a bit of a headache too but i didn't
really have it yesterday but
okay and it wasn't even like that sore
at the time too just doing it
out of an abundance of caution it felt
off but
you know well
i don't know how to do that yeah
anyway uh glad you're feeling okay and
uh don't worry don't feel anxious it's
not your fault all right
thank you thank you for saying so yeah
absolutely and people in the chat are
pointing out that it it's a little um
it's a little uncool that you guys
didn't invite olivia to play fortnite
with you
olivia does not want to play fortnite
with that olivia has to focus on her
education thank you for the play with
her but and even when i'm home
i would love to not
she's more of a ceo he's more of a cs go
player really you know what olivia
what if we start our own gaming team
just you and me olivia
you and me we can we can download life
is strange
or sims
i mean i don't feel sick i mean this
morning i was
this morning i felt a little congested
but i i don't know if it's from the ac
because in the basement i have the fan
running non-stop to keep like the
ventilation going
and so i don't know if just my throat
was dry from that
but i feel fine
you know
that's good it's weird being in the
basement not being able to see the kids
yeah that's rough rough timing
theater and from upstairs he's like
daddy
why can't you come play with me
that's so sad and i went up there with
my mask and sat across from him and
didn't let him like touch me or come
near me but
i got a response from the doctor
actually okay go ahead
uh the guidelines have kind of gone
crazy if he is vaccinated they actually
don't require quarantine isolation but
if he wants to be cautious he could wait
five days and test on third and fifth
day
this is all anecdotal though because
official cdc guidelines say that if you
get covet you only have to quarantine
for five days and if you are exposed by
vaccinated you don't have the quarantine
at all but with omnicron it may not be
as bad idea to wait five days and test
on days three and five try to get pcrs
that's even considering my newborn son
yeah
i told him he said if you're a
systematic and positive it will only
catch
30th percentage of the time
oh wow
yeah
really kind of awful in my opinion
yeah so um bare minimum wait five days
okay so he's saying wait five days
yeah
he said what in his opinion it's awful
off
i know this is about uh
about the a systematic
symptoms
[Music]
oh if you are symptomatic and positive
it will tell you 65 of the time really
kind of awful in my opinion oh the
testing uh yeah i see got it
well if i take a lot of tests then the
chance of catching it is better right i
mean
i'm not catching it of testing i mean
testing
of uh not having a false test right
right
right
right right all right let's move on
thank you a.b
uh we should do the ads oh okay having
too much fun out here yeah
thank you
first of all to mint mogul
love our boys over at mint mobile saving
more and spending less is one of your
top goals for 2022 why are you still
paying insane amounts of money every
month for wireless switching mobile is
the easiest way to save this year as the
first company to sell premium wireless
service online only
mobile lets you maximize your savings
with plants starting at just 15 dollars
a month dan uses mint mobile actually
that's it i i love it the price you
can't beat
and uh
i'll be frank it's it's just as good as
as the big boys
use the same name they use the same they
use the same network yeah exactly and so
there's just really no reason to to make
the switch same service just cheaper for
people looking for extra savings this
year mint mobiles offer premium wireless
for just 15 bucks a month and by going
online only eliminating the traditional
cost of retail mint mobile passes these
significant savings on to you all
playing come with unlimited talk and
text high-speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network you can use
your own phone with any mint mobile plan
and keep the same number along with all
your existing contacts and with bimobile
choose the amount of monthly data that's
right for you and stop paying for data
that you never use switch to mint mobile
and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month they
get your new wireless plan for just 15
bucks a month and to get the plans
shipped right to your door for free go
to mintmobile.com
h3 that's minmobile.com h3 cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks about that
mobile.com
h3 thank you
next thank you to honey
today's episode sponsored by honey the
easy way to save when shopping on your
iphone or
computer
love honey
i can't speak enough about it
every time i'm online
every time i'm shopping especially ila
she doesn't waste all my shopping she's
like boom save 20 bucks boom saved 100
bucks boom saved
393 bucks
right here i don't remember what ela
bought i think it was like a rug or
something
but that's the that's the magic you know
you just shop you go to the checkout you
don't expect any savings but then they
just no they just find it and they add
it it's easy it's instant it's free it's
a no-brainer thanks to honey manual
suture for coupon codes is a thing of
the past honey's the free shopping tool
that discovers the internet for promo
codes and applies the best when it finds
your cart imagine you're shopping at one
of your favorite sites and when you hit
the checkout button honey the honey
button appears and all you have to do is
click apply coupon wait a few seconds is
honey searches for coupons you can find
for that site and if honey finds a
coupon you will watch the price drop
basically magically dude
honey doesn't work on desk honey doesn't
just work on desktops anymore you can
actually use it on your iphone just
activate it on safari and your phone on
your phone and save on the go and if you
don't already have honey you could be
straight up missing out and by getting
it you're doing yourself a solid and
supporting this show i love honey i use
honey i recommend it get honey for free
at jointhoney.com
h3 that's joinhoney.com
h3
thank you thank you and finally
[Music]
mint uh liquid iv
[Laughter]
liquid iv man
it's hydrating yourself it's better than
water
it's more efficient than water it's got
vitamins to support your immune system
it's got a boost one with caffeine in it
you know coffee messed my stomach up
it's very acidic
this is great give me that boost while
getting staying hydrated boosted
boosted
uh there's like i don't know there's all
kinds of flavors and different vitamin
packs and purposes i like the watermelon
one the watermelon one what does it do
is it just a hydration one that one's
hydration yeah
i usually do the chugging meme while
we're doing this but i've got like i'm
doing like 15 yeah 20 uh main frames
going i don't have it but it's like
keying out
oh you have some oh you have a whole
pack of it oh it's king okay yeah i mean
it's just a little tube
um you put it in water you mix it up and
then you got yourself a great beverage
you put in six ounces of water to
hydrate faster and more efficient than
water alone they've got beautiful
flavors like watermelon lemon lime
strawberry pina colada and more
tastes great
functions great
it's great for a workout
it's great after a run it's great for
daily uh hydration maintenance hangover
recovery
it's poppin you say you like the
watermelon one
yeah
they're all good though you feel good
after you take it right yeah feel still
juiced up as love would say yeah
um
you know contains over five essential
vitamins b3 b5 b6 b12 and vitamin c
that's a lot of bees oh my god
baby with a b and three times the
electrolytes of traditional sports
drinks made with premium ingredients
non-gmo and free from gluten dairy and
soy
because you know we ain't no soy boys
you know what i'm saying
they've donated also over 19 million
servings globally so they're basically
saints on top of everything else
grab liquid iv in bulk and nationwide at
costco or you can get 25 off when you go
to liquidity.com and use code h3 at
checkout that's 25 off anything you
order wow when you use the promo code h3
at liquidity.com
experience better hydration today at
liquidity.com promo code h3
yeah baby
all right
[Music]
bro at this rate we're not going to get
to the video because like there's so
much stuff maybe we should save it like
we have a whole tribute to wendy
williams whose show is ending we should
save the fousey video no no the wendy
williams wendy williams yeah uh we could
save that for friday
we did a whole we put a whole tribute
together because that's going to be like
an hour tribute man i mean
she's so important to the show
clap
clap if you want him to suffer
uh
jeff widdick by the way i made a video
on the ethan klein channel this is just
more of a
an announcement but if you guys want to
stay up to date with some of memes going
over the ethan klein channel but i
announced here
that uh
jeff is coming on the show next friday
best friends but you still didn't fix
the title
jet oh my god that was the title of the
video
i thought it was just the description
cam
you said it was just the description
it was title and
holy [ __ ] bro and i dropped the
screenshot too
i can't believe it said jet width this
whole time
i thought it was just the description
bro what the hell here i'm fixing it
right now
jet width
i see somebody saying look at jeff
tweets right now
is there some
new update i put them in the dock oh you
did okay
i did not mean to call you jet bro
well and then and then dan pointed out
that like oh no i wasn't gonna bring
this up well it's not it's not but
there's a guy in cowboy beep bop named
jet with a bionic eye
and i was like i don't want to be
sliding
but i just had a i just had a paralysis
game when i looked at cam's feed
and saw oh my god
that was not my intention i just fixed
it i'm such an idiot bro
probably have way more views if i
spelled his name right
i was like who the [ __ ] a jet
[Laughter]
anyway
he's coming on the show next friday i'm
very happy to
to sit down and have another
chat with him
oh jeff wait jeff's uh
he's live tweeting right now
he said uh i'm no longer part of the
roast of bryce hall my entire set will
be cut due to censorship and david
dobrik being involved i refuse to be a
part of anything that scumbags involved
in from here on out so wait is it david
dobrik or is it censorship i'm confused
he says i'm no longer a part of the
roast well maybe they said that he
couldn't make any jokes about david and
so he was like [ __ ] that
or is he saying is he saying david had a
hand in getting him
removed from it that will be cut due to
censorship and david dobrik being
involved
uh
maybe he's just like yeah they don't
they're saying i can't say certain jokes
and dave is involved so i forget about
it right
and we'll ask him about it next friday
everyone's like wait what
people are saying i'm i'm confident jeff
is joking see they don't know
there's actually this isn't a joke jeff
has has 100
gone against the family
sure seems like it unless we're getting
got too no no no no i've been i've been
listening i've been following
that whole patreon live stream that was
that was raw
somebody in the chat said they already
filmed it so maybe he would yeah
the the top comment says he probably
made a bunch of david related jokes and
then they like wanted to cut around them
maybe
and then he just didn't want to be
associated huh
i like jeff he's my new best friend i
was saying he should become a cast
member
maybe a co-host even
new heartthrob
oh yeah
ab
watch out jeff's joining the crew
you have such a man crush on jeff it's
interesting
yeah he's my best friend
who did it i love jeff
who did that
jet whittake
such a dumb ass the t looks just like
the f it's literally the same letter
except one
it just goes to the right at the top a
little bit catty corner from each other
yeah yeah caddy corner like dan said
he's also been tweeting about david's
hairline
oh my gosh wait why did
he hey look he's sponsored again
congrats you bald eagle
wait receding hairline c key seed geek
called baldi dobrik 75 that doesn't seem
like a
real ad
does it
yeah
it's not
so the top comment is jeff best enough
to burn your bridges during a time of
emotional turbulence guys give him a
break
david has literally ruined his life and
doesn't give a single frick about him
come on guys these dobrik fans are so
so sad
let jeff have his moment
burn it and not being allowed to burn a
bridge with someone who almost killed
you
yeah he was like literally he was
a millimeter away from kill literally
ending his life and he doesn't have the
decency to call the guy checking on him
i personally think jeff should still sue
him
get that bag
i agree
get it get the bag jeff
unless you sign something with him
already but
he says he didn't
you guys like this millie bobby brown
turned 18 and of course you guys can
only imagine i'm just reading this
twitter headline you can imagine the
foulness that she's encountering now boy
in fact you probably shouldn't
ross right
twitter i'm assuming it's curated
because it's like on the side it's one
of those okay
but there's like a as always happens a
countdown uh timer
and all this disgusting debate i hope
she doesn't go off the rails like so
many of these kid actors do
she seems pretty uh together i mean
especially i think so
but um
netflix family tweeted declaring today a
national holiday
because she turned 18
well just because it's it's also just a
birthday i mean right that's true okay
but yeah um as you can imagine men are
just men more and more are just i'm
realizing such pigs bro
there's such
vile freaks men are
we'll do that
anyway happy birthday i guess
and uh so i'm so i'm excited i don't
know how you guys feel but but i'm
actually excited to sit down and talk
with my new bestie
no i'm glad he's coming on i think it'll
be a really interesting episode and
it'll be good for you guys to
to hash everything out a little bit
yeah new best friend
my friend my friendship ended
or i guess the meme's him friendship
ended with dobrik
my new best friend is ethan your best
friend
fun
people saying there's a newer uh jeff
tweet than the one about the uh rose for
real i i think he's he's let's go to his
specifically going off 11 minutes ago
there you go i chose to have my set cut
they tried to remove half of my jokes
this was supposed to be a comedy show i
didn't say anything i wouldn't say in my
own you
do video podcast this is all because
that coward was there and he can't take
jokes wait david actually asked people
to cut jokes that's crazy if he that's
what happened because he was probably
making jokes about like trying to kill
him or
god forbid the yeah because usually at
those roasts they make jokes they they
also roast the other
participants but that's
you try to demolish them right
so why is david dobrik at a brice hall
roast anyway or maybe he was i don't
know i could ask jeff about that sounds
real interesting
i like off the rails jeff
love it
stan off the rails jeff
such a cool dude so [ __ ] cool that
guy
[Laughter]
anyway
let's get to the uh the main show here
so we have a lot to talk about tomorrow
oh there's one thing i want to talk
about sorry oh there's one other thing
because i
you know
i hate logan paul
he's a straight up scammer
dink doink
dang dink doink is my favorite scam
here he they are haggling some poor guy
in the street but they actually look
like such douche bags some of what you
guys think about this
let me turn the quality up
at this point
it feels intentional something like
they're like we're gonna wait for him to
blink and go cross side to take the
photo what are you saying yeah i think
you got the wrong guy
he said aren't you that guy that got
knocked out by mayweather
you having fun
you having a good time it's nice yeah
you can tell bro look at you you're
having a good ass time huh
yeah look at it look at him he's having
a blast famous nah you favorites look at
how you dress
you got squalls on your shirt white g's
brand new kicks
what the [ __ ] is this he's like words
what the [ __ ] are those where's the fans
you are you're the fan bro look at you
standing around us you're the guy
waiting for my uber
you fat [ __ ] you hurt me [ __ ] gets in
the car and drives away get to the prius
mike is such a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] god
the fact that they uploaded this that's
what i'm saying and mike is so so
irredeemable like the guy goes oh didn't
you get aren't you the guy that got his
ass beat by mayweather
and then they're like look at you you
[ __ ] nerd with your new shoes and
shirt you fat [ __ ]
it just shows how insecure they are just
be like yeah that was me yeah why you
got to check the answer is yes yes
that is me
but like they thought it was cool they
uploaded it i mean even if they are
[ __ ] like they thought it was cool
to show like they don't see what's wrong
it's it's i can't
it's getting in your they're like he's
like where's your fans which is kind of
funny right because it's logan paul he
thinks he's like the most famous guy in
the world he wants to be president
he goes oh you're our fan he's like nah
i'm just here for an uber and then when
he gets into uber you're running away
from us you fat [ __ ] i wanted to fight
you apparently that's what mike's
insinuating right
running away is uber arrived what do you
expect you you
you want him to
the uber to leave without him that's a
ten dollar charge
and fight you or something
what's this we're like it's a calling
called maverick he goes it's a word also
he could have actually just been a fan
making a joke you know what i mean like
he could have just legit just been a fan
of making a joke like oh aren't you i
got knocked out by mayweather
didn't he to be fair he didn't strike me
as a fan
he's definitely talking [ __ ] yeah he was
he was he was definitely just being a
smart ass you know a little bit
but to be fair maverick is a really dumb
it is really dumb
you know
it's embarrassing to call yourself a
maverick
okay
i mean that's a fair assessment stopped
by mayweather
yeah dude you having fun we're shooting
at cold open for i don't even know what
he's going on about you having fun out
here you all dressed up
you're in your shoes he's just trying to
do the talking down condescending kind
of thing you having fun little guy
trying to act like you have money
glasses you got pants on there buddy
i see you have pants on you having fun
out here
you know little haircut you having fun
nice socks let's see you having fun out
here
these guys are so hateable where's the
fans you are you're the fan bro look at
you standing around us you're the guy
you're waiting for by uber what are you
even saying huh
yo you're the fat french montana
you fat [ __ ] you heard me [ __ ] gets in
the car and drives away
got him he's fat
mike
look i always say this but we know why
mike is like this
sloppy drawers he needs a fresh pair of
shorts
he's such a [ __ ] dude mike is such a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
uh
the prius
what's this we're like it's callie brad
called maverick he goes
it's a word yo you got knocked out by
mayweather
yeah did you having fun
he obviously got you pretty good i mean
he's definitely pissed he definitely
seemed bothered so if you guys see logan
on the street you know what to say to
bother him
what you should not do by the way do not
don't don't don't say anything if you
see logan leave him alone i don't know i
i like mike
i just
i'm just a i don't know what you're
trying to do
nice try
what happened to love he turned into
like a
a guy friend he looks like he's
diazified he looks like he's on a house
selling uh reality show cam too what do
you mean this is just
it's just a light filter to smooth my
skin
yeah i just came with my camera it's not
no big deal this is just life at the
airbnb man
we're living large out here
because a good good lighting over there
your guys apartment yeah good lighting
um
sorry to be a buzzkill but did you see
the part immediately after the hater
part there
no cold open for the oliver tree podcast
he has the world's biggest
yeah i know i didn't want to do this but
oliver
i get it he has to promote his stuff
but i need to see that episode before i
totally turn on oliver
you know
[Applause]
let me watch this whole thing what
exactly do you do short videos about my
life okay um
yeah i'm not interested dan
is the car here let's go all right hey
dude you have a bright future ahead of
you you know your brother jake yeah
he's a talent man and i think if you
keep up and you try to just spend some
time with him having your mentor
maybe one day you could do something
with your life
super bowl monday
gotta see that podcast
just to know
but he got to promote his stuff i get it
you know it's a popular podcast
less popular than ours but he he was
measuring
if he uh yeah not as popular as ours is
that what you said yeah not on the chart
not even close right or were they close
it was close yeah so i mean oliver is
not he's he's not helping
he needs to go there and like spit in
their face or some [ __ ] i mean he fought
me so expect
at least at least that kind of a
stabbing maybe
anyway
okay let's get let's finally get to the
keemstar cringe uh temple
archive
but before we do
what else you got
oh boy
teddy fresh
this the sweater i'm wearing right now
is the uh it's this here
this is the plaid polar fleece jacket
look at those colors man wow the orange
and yellow it's actually super it looks
like a jacket but it's fleece
i really like that one i might have to
yeah grab one of those you know the
colors are are awesome there's so much
to pick up and tomorrow our elton john
um collab comes out as well
head on over to teddy fresh and see if
you see something you like
this sweater is really beautiful too
which i need to
get one for myself
um is our website just fun okay there
you go anyway teddyfresh.com go check it
out see if something you like okay
all right now on to the main event
[Applause]
fouseytube
x keemstar the movie
wow now this is apparently where
keemstar met his 20 year old
girlfriend as well
so there's actually
we think
there's a lot of lore potentially yeah
uh stemming from now i want to say
something right off the bat because i
know keemstar is going to be writing an
email to youtube to get this
every time i mention keemstar i
mysteriously get
a manual review that says inciting hate
hmm against the individual i'm like
that's so weird i never get that against
um
anyone else never
and it always happens after the fact by
like three days
weird
so i want to say i'm not here to incite
hate this is criticism of keemstar
okay
and fouseytube
the criticism
we will see
but do not incite hate maybe you'll like
it even i mean i do yeah i'm a fan of
their work they're boxing stuff that
they do is super cool yeah and and
keemstar is really talented with his
boxing commentary
really why are you so cute when you talk
[ __ ] i'm not talking [ __ ] i'm actually
saying nice things about you
oh my god
real quick
ian show the cat everybody nobody's
going to settle down until you show the
[ __ ] cat
the chat is nothing go ahead we got
yeah the cat looks really big is that a
big cat she's just no she's pretty small
but she's really fluffy very fluffy
her name's penny she's very cute
you're very cute
adorable
thank you thank you i'll let her know
you hear that all right
thank you everyone
and you're welcome
chad even what you doing i was just
when you're talking to hila we're
interested in the cap well there's a cat
thing going on i had to say something
here
anyway
so i just want to make clear
this is not hate do not send hate to
keemstar or fousey
this is commentary and criticism will be
very measured in our response we'll be
very respectful as well
right everyone
oh absolutely and again
this might
this might make you change your mind
about them so this is fusing keemstar
the movie the pairing of these two is
just endlessly bizarre because you know
keemstar tried to ruin fousey's life for
many many years to the point where
fousey even said on video during his
breakdown at his uh iconic drake
concert at the greek that never happened
oh my god
that he almost he wanted to
un-alive himself because of of what
keemstar did and he wouldn't be the
first one actually
weirdly then i mean and then keem later
put that on a t-shirt
he did
if i'm not mistaken yeah i believe so
let's confirm that that's pretty wild if
so
oh that makes me want to puke
which is kind of true
well we'll fact check that okay
but i mean i feel bad for foosie i see
fousey as the victim here he's desperate
for relevancy he's depressed he's also
desperate for keemstar to like
like him in the way that he wishes he
would just leave him alone because he
has tormented him for so long like he
did me
that if you can befriend keemstar then
the onslaught stops and i think he's
just he needs that reprieve right and i
think that's what a lot of people do
when it comes to keemstar is they
they just submit because
being enemies with keemstar is uh
not something a lot of people want to
get involved
understandably so
so that being said this is the keemstar
fussy movie
let's do it
[Music]
wow that's badass right out the gate
what is who's that batman
wait let me go back oh is that batman
okay wait i need to figure out a way to
go back
and not move so much
yo the arrow keys use the arrow keys to
navigate right but that's just like one
frame no no like left right
that's like one frame the arrow keys
and then there's j and l but it goes
back maybe too much but it's okay arrow
keys
did you guys find the t-shirt skip back
and forth like five seconds at a time
i'm still looking i'm seeing some people
say that it was
whenever fousey went on no jumper and
like he lost his mind on that podcast it
was that that keemstar had on his shirt
which i believe was shortly after it was
part of the thing well well let's find
the shirt you know that's that's
important
yo yo is that batman
[Music]
crazy yo the atvs
yo these guys are so freaking cool
atvs
little scooters with big wheels
i'm in
muddin and up
just a couple just a couple boys getting
muddy together that's right that's right
brother let's mut it up
dude
there's so much to look forward to in
this film
oh no he got stuck in the mud
yo
[Music]
oh my god
oh my god we're in keemstar's house
wait is this really his house this is a
really interesting perspective
[Music]
wait that's his front door it doesn't
look that like sturdy so no it's not
it's the door to the garage okay i'm
there's
a little something about the front door
actually that i will point out to you
later but uh but yeah for now that
that's the garage because like that
looks like pretty flimsy but it makes
sense if it's a garage yeah
god fussy went too far on the um
veneers to any
with peace and love
the veneers are so in style right now
and i'm just really turning on it people
are taking the veneers way too far do
you guys agree
you notice that it's a little uncanny
valley it's like when somebody it's what
a similar effect is the uh people that
get too much plastic surgery you know
yeah it's just
it doesn't look real dude it looks like
you're wearing like comic teeth
olivia thoughts on veneers
i 100 agree i think if you're gonna get
them you should ask for them to be
like
coffee stand middle yeah like real
little on the color scale right nobody
has teeth that way yeah i mean there's
really good veneers that you can get
that look great yeah they don't have to
be pure white like that
it's wild to me but it's not just the
whiteness it's the shape it's the size
it's the whole thing she's out of
control
some people you can tell they have like
wicked gum disease with it
and the gums come over the veneers it's
wild bro it's a whole wild scene
and he's not here
[Applause]
this is his garage no it's in his ass
what's up everybody me and my team are a
little delirious right now because we
just woke up literally in keemstar's
house and he's not even here don't
believe me come check he's not the first
person to just mysteriously wake up in
keemstar's house oh [ __ ]
that's a joke
this is keemstar his natural habitat
he's often seen he's he's out he's out
roaming at pasture
a beautiful scenery he's out uh eating
grass
you know
crazy he's grazing with the herd right
now
running in the wild running through the
woods looking for the latest scoop to
keep you in the loop this is where he
sits down and looks for all the drama
that's gonna unfold on youtube there's
bryce hall and tana mojo making out got
a report
not good
[Laughter]
not good stuff but on that one
i've never seen bryce or tana make out
so nobody run with that but i want to
show you guys how hospitable keem was
when we walked into his house this note
was on the bed
he wrote that he took his time to write
that he also took his what what was that
his name was there a note or something
in it did he write something like hey
dude welcome like why would you write a
note
just a note
like semi folded up like you remember
the first paper page piece of paper you
ever folded
maybe you were like five and you're like
dang this is hard to get right look at
that thing's folded man
what the heck why did he do that you
guys is that hamburger style or hot dog
style
it's hard to tell frankly it's not a
good fold
not a good phone keemstar's watching
like seriously they're what they're
criticizing my fold
it is
it's remarkable it's pretty nitpicky
yeah it is but it is remarkable
it is a bad hole it's a bad fold i mean
what can i say the man can't fold a
piece of paper
i think it's worth noting
she wrote that he took his time to write
that how hospitable it's time to write
this do not use the shower but he bought
me and sven a whole outfit brand new to
go atv riding today i'm going deer
hunting or something he even got me
boost but the nicest thing also sofusy
don't be jealous then he gave me the
face murakami collab that was like
really appreciated he did not have to do
that i brought him a present too he
wanted something for his bar collection
now before he gets here let's sneak down
this bar and show you guys what he's
working with come down here beer
garden this way welcome to keane's bar
okay okay we ain't gonna touch any of
that alcohol but okay you got a pinball
machine you got a video game machine you
got a jukebox you got a pool table you
know what's crazy is he doing like a
cribs i think he's trying to do like a
crib yeah
we love the keem bar don't we folks
so cool i mean if you're trying to
impress a 20 year old
it's a good place to take them yeah
i'll tell you what
all the coolest uh clubs and bars have
uh
have a vr uh racing car simulator i'll
tell you what corner down in keemstar's
bar
they don't check id
you better believe it baby well if i'm
not mistaken this isn't his main home
this is sort of his uh fun house if you
will
his other house has the pool in the
backyard and it's more of his living uh
area
this is the party house what a player
dude
yeah
too bad the showers don't work in it
do not use this shower
there's a trough in the back for you to
help to wash off and
freeze
he says not to use the shower because
that's always where he films his videos
so he's got a full screen what he does
he films all the time i got i got it set
up just right for audio completely yeah
that's where he films all his hate
videos in the bathroom
ethan is a freaking hypocrite
fousey keep it down
don't talk lucy
just about all this today is july 12th
july 12th three years ago i was with
keem as well but he was creating a
documentary on me going crazy unfolding
what was happening during july 15. the
fact that three years later life brought
us back together and now i am staying
over his house ready to make a giant
announcement to work the next boxing
event with him life is crazy that's all
i can say team i really appreciate it
we're about to have a lot of fun can't
wait for you to be here in three two one
watch this we heard the garage so five
four
bro you could have cut that
it's doing it
how many count no dude that's why you
edit your video
you don't need two countdowns
you seem to miss the point of the
editing experience
we don't need every take you did
three
two
one
zero
[Applause]
you made it yes sir guess what i got a
gift
i went to the butcher got some real
maple syrup we got the italian cheese
the smoked cheese cheese pepper stick we
got real jerky and that's pretty much it
but yeah
i hooked it up so yeah what the hell
kind of
meal is he planning
i got a gift for you a jug of maple
syrup boy
and some beef jerky
some more beef and some more and i got
some beef jerky what
we eating good tonight
um i ain't got time to cook i just eat
beef jerky maple syrup
down here in buffalo new york
we went to the butcher and you expect
you like got like steaks some fillets
like some jerky some more turkey
like them smoked meats boy
yo
he's like yo i went to the butcher and
hooked us up for dinner i got some
beautiful t-bones
no i got us some beef jerky for dinner
bro like four different times though
i'd like sick what's for dinner
cool beef jerky
yeah guys like i said we're at
keemstar's house thanks for having us uh
it's gonna be a lot of fun we're going
atv and we're gonna go mini bike riding
no you see the barrier he did go down
dude that's all he does dude you see the
bar
yes we saw the bar ready we've seen it
like a hundred times but okay let's go
back to the bar again could have cut
this we already saw the bar fizzy or you
could've cut the one before
we put a lot of work into this place
dude so so cut the first part
we don't need two tours of the bar
fusion
[Music]
he's doing the same thing you just did
we have the black light underneath and
we got the glow in the dark ball are you
good
yo maybe they maybe as a third friend
comes over we could get a third tour of
the of the bar area closer look please
yeah
really good are you good
i'll take those i got an early 1980s
jukebox here that plays the real records
and then of course i got my racing
simulator we'll have to get on that
digital
ball like 100 different boards you play
like different games
all right so show me the bar start
show me the bar and then you just pull
the thing and then
oh that is ridiculous wait it's not even
real it's not a real yeah it's like a
digital uh i'm not gonna lie it's kind
of cool i can't i like it i like pinball
rare job for keemstar
but does it play like a real machine i
wonder
uh i'm sure purists would tell you no
but it's i'm sure it's fine
how would you know it's fine
because i'm not a pinball purist i'm not
a pinball wizard and then how can who
are you qualified to say that you're
right i'm not qualified
i'm so sorry let me make a retraction
retract that i do not know if that's a
cool pinball machine thank you see
keemstar your pinball machine sucks you
heard it here
no dubs for keemstar
we got the bar top show oh he showed the
bar sick here's a karaoke machine
obviously we got the fireplace if you
follow keem's home renovations on
twitter you will have seen that this is
wait that fireplace is kind of dope but
it's not a real phone no i love this
thing this thing's dope it's a digital
screen but the heat actually comes on i
feel it no i feel it i feel it it's hot
yeah okay
speakers these are classic speakers and
then these are like relatively new how
do we bump that who's your favorite
artist j cole shuffling songs by jake i
like j cole but the fact that he's
fussy's favorite artist does say a lot
what do you think about that ian
in thoughts
the what
bro what are you doing are you playing
video games right now what are you doing
no i'm sorry i wouldn't go to la croix
[ __ ] that was not a lacroix
distraction you're doing something
i'm not doing nothing
can you see a screen dan i can't
unfortunately i can't bust himself i'm
going to have to install screen
screen viewers on your computer because
the ian did today okay i'm sorry i got a
i got a message from our vet
veterinarian i have a cat appointment at
three o'clock tomorrow that's what it
was yeah right you're just saying that
i'm telling you i'll screenshot it and
send it to you i will i believe you got
the message you're just covering up
playing fortnite
and how's it how was the new world today
was it funny
i haven't played that come on where are
we at what's going on here fousey said
his favorite
artist is j cole how do you feel about
that
i don't what's the problem with that
i like j cole i just think it's funny
that people
i don't know okay no problem with it i'm
just
analyzing everything
okay [ __ ] i think it does say something
about him okay moving on
take hold on amazon music
straight up glow in the black light
look at that [ __ ] they're like
fluorescent
when your teeth look like that you've
gone too far man
is the devil that's actually our
favorite song once we have the music
popping let's go
hey i can't listen to that [ __ ]
whatever's playing in the bars played
out here man that's a dream life man it
reminds me when i lived in new jersey
i'm about to add like a huge fountain
out there right now we got this little
guy all of the land that you can see
i'm in the process of buying
he's like yeah my dream is to have
hookers run for their lives and i snipe
them off the porch
most dangerous game is the most
dangerous game if they escape
i go to jail
if i win
they die
i'll give you a spoiler
i don't lose
they don't look under this here porsche
neither
childhood butcher he lives around the
corner you gotta try this okay first
we're gonna do let's do the cheese first
spicy italian got a ton of flavor on it
[ __ ] chews like me it's good yeah all
right now this is the smoked cheese this
content is so dumb you guys
yo
this
i don't even think fousey liked it like
he had no comment about it i don't think
he likes any of it
let's do the cheese first spicy italian
got a ton of flavor on it
he hates it this is good he literally
keemstar said it's good
all right now this is the smoked cheese
all right you guys are big on cheese i
love cheese love meat like normally i
would get bread cheese and meat in one
bite
right you'd have like an actual meal
what i'm trying to say is i'm hungry
dude
that's something right
take a bite of one of these this is the
hot cheese peppers
yup
dude he's worse than me yeah that's bad
too
that chili needs work man they take it
maybe is it the veneers maybe maybe
makes it hard
i don't know like a horse with peanut
butter
mr ed over here
that's good okay now this is the best
this is just regular cheese and pepper
stick
keeps giving me cheese
close your goddamn mat is this what it's
like when i chew um it's not that bad i
think it's
this is worse but we're on the same
spectrum here for sure i chew with my
mouth open during the show
you do
did we did we point out that olivia
we were talking before the show she's
pro chewing oh yeah that declaration we
didn't have her hair on monday but she
was like i love the chewing i love the
eating you like hearing the sound of
chewing
i don't pay attention to the sound of
chewing i like when when you eat i feel
like
because i watch mook bombs and stuff
like that hmm
is this doing something for you
eating cheese
um not necessarily but i don't hate the
sound
i don't like this sound though
she's taking it too far can you pull up
by a clip of mr ed chewing peanut butter
we could compare and contrast
thoughts it tastes like beef jerky yeah
yeah yeah it is beef jerk that's such an
interesting insight from uh
from fusi
he should be a food critic
here taste this beef jerky it tastes
like beef jerky
it's so interesting that they kept this
in
let me go back and get that it tastes
like beef jerky
yo can we sound bite that zach
sure i'll put
yo you guys it tastes like
this is the most petty ridiculous um
episode we've ever done by the way just
for that oh we yeah we knew i understand
that this is
just an absurd episode okay
people are saying that's literally you
ethan
okay let's listen to well then who's
worse me
fousey or
mr ed go ahead dan
uh
here
that's what he looks like when he's
munching peanut bar yeah apparently
he's telling the nose eh
dude that's a talented horse right there
that's
pretty gnarly
oh my god
that's just peanut butter right
apparently
that's how they did it interesting i was
hoping for some audio but okay it's back
in the day
you know
yeah yeah yeah it's a pepper stick um
now this is like real jerky
there's no way i'm that bad there's no
way
bring me food to eat right now and you
guys can come back
bring me a pop-tart or something that's
good
it's got to be like maple syrup wait
wait don't tell me you take maple syrup
by itself for this what i would do is
rip a little piece of jerky exactly dip
it in exactly maple syrup that you get
in the store is not real maple syrup
it's made out of corn syrup this is real
authentic maple syrup don't double dips
man i know you like double dipping
what are they doing
the man came for a meal and he's he's
eating maple syrup with a fork off a
plate
this is not hospital this is not
hospitality this is just odd behavior
dude oh god yo hit this maple syrup with
this fork bro
let's eat some lunch right now
i can't even get used to it because it
goes down so easy it's like smooth so
smooth okay be careful when he gets
drunk because he's gonna start chugging
this
man's gonna start chucking the maple
syrup pause
okay go back no right there right there
is perfect okay
notice
i believe
that is his front door
okay
there's it's blocked
hmm
or is that just maybe it's just like a
wallpaper or something to cover the
glass
that's definitely a bookcase that's like
a bookcase but it might be one it might
be a flat image
just for decoration
what
to cover the glass because there's like
a glass door
you think it's a real bookcase yeah
that's it because then he drilled into
his front door
no it doesn't have to be drilled it
could just be
you know stationary it's enough that you
just can't get out you know right maybe
he's afraid like zombies coming or
something oh i don't know yeah he came
in through the garage
right see that looks kind of like a flat
image like it could just be
i i see what you're talking about i
think it's just an optical illusion from
the light coming in from behind it it's
making it look flatter than it is we saw
another frame where uh
it was it seemed more apparent that it
was a people are saying it's a flat
image
or people saying it has depth
huh it's a hotly debated issue
is keemstar's front door
barricaded
i don't know what you're talking about
that is interesting
what do we make of this guys
no front door if it's flat or not it's
blocking the front door's blocked yeah
yeah yeah yeah
it's blocked you didn't get now if it's
image you could still open the door
he just puts it there to block the
the glass
yeah maybe
maybe you don't want people to see in
because yeah there's a road
yeah that's kind of weird in itself i
mean you could just replace the door bro
you've lived there long enough you
degenerate you could tint the windows
there's a bunch you could do
i mean
it's just odd you know he's i think it's
just one room i there i think he usually
sleeps in the living room i've seen he
sleeps in the living room that's my
understanding of
just he probably got so used to his
girlfriend making him sleep on the couch
that he just
stationed there
right so
i think i think he usually sleeps in his
living room i'm not sure though
so maybe it is just to block the light
yeah oh keem told us to change because
he said it's about to get a little
i'm sorry [ __ ] but look at the teeth
do you think those are too white guys
it's like
it's blinding good
to have to get a little dirty so look
what i'm wearing and then look at what
ben is wearing
yo are those are those vitamins
are these the new yeezy boots
that's crazy those are like thousand
dollar yeezys
this gives me roman atwood vibes i got
that brand new trick yo keem what's this
dead uh woman doing here
with a sniper shot in her back
oh don't worry about that
let's just say she lost
batter and it will put you on that and
make you drive it it's it's a lot
okay rule number one guys never let me
get behind anything that drives but if
he's gonna do it he's gonna do it is
this where you chop wood in the morning
yup built that sack myself out of that
tree you actually did
i told you guys in the beginning of the
video when i said this is team's natural
habitat i wasn't lying
team came be careful when sven's drunk
he's probably gonna try to swim in here
that's gonna be awesome yeah you gotta
be careful and spend drunk you know what
i'm surprised oh no you have it at the
other house i was gonna say you don't
have a swimming pool but you do you have
one of them you have a really nice swing
we're building an indoor one here it's
gonna be underground
dude no freaking way
a couple of dudes
this whole thing is formatted like a an
episode of the bachelor
that's true they're on a diet they're on
a date he showed up he had a new outfit
he had a new outfit it's like we're
going on an adventure today totally and
i wonder if he's going to get the rose
yeah
oh he
he went by rose at one point remember he
changed his name oh yeah
uh
um
you you guys know by the way every time
keemstar brings a new girl back they go
atv ready
yeah we got some air
but yeah that's what we're going to be
doing in the woods but now let's get on
the mini bike
sick
yeah he's got keemstar stickers on his
mini bikes bro
you see that you got the kim stuff out
there
yeah this is the movie by the way you
guys enjoying this plot
the fuji keemstar movie eh
yeah why is he keeps keep picking on his
sven the camera guy making him seem like
an alcoholic
this [ __ ] dumb dream oh this guy's
gonna drink you better hide that bleach
sven's gonna drink that when he
gets drunk so [ __ ] dumb yeah
yo
yo you better put the knives away sven
gets crazy when he drinks
[Music]
am i crazy are those like really mini
bikes
are mini bikes supposed to be that small
love what does love think he's the bike
yeah the bike guy i mean it looks like a
90cc bike over there
uh they're pretty fun to drive to be
fair but that's the right size
i mean
they're small bikes yeah and it's it's
kind of kind of weird that they're like
two four year old men
both holding
just driving around in their backyard
i think so too
it's kind of odd but you know to be fair
it's it's probably fun yeah it looks
fine it does look fun it looks fun it
looks fun
i'd give keem the rose if he took me on
this date
all right
watch out bud
it's so small
scooting around
it died
oh i thought he was gonna go bareback
[Music]
nice short weather out there in buffalo
but on my george such a good look the
high high roots in the george
it looks like a good time i mean i can't
i can't take it away from him yeah
you know couple bad boys out on the
prairie
oh my god
it's a good thing i own six of them
yeah so keem starts feeling so insecure
that one of his bikes don't work he
actually started to get really upset you
can tell
he's like yo i don't own this crap what
well good thing i own six of them for
some reason
yo i have 20 of these in my garage don't
even trip bro
oh he got it
yo look at the guys
yeah
oh he slipped like a banana peel
so bad it's so fast he's going like
eight miles per hour
now that's fun i'm just trying to make
comment commentary but
someone said it reminds me of one of
those early 2000's mtv day reality
dating shows so true but the music the
sound effects everything 1000 that's
spot on brokeback mountain vibe someone
said true
just a couple of good old boys
i got a tent up by the about the way
that i don't know about
why don't we take a ride up there and
explore each other's bodies
kill some hookers together
[Music]
here's the deal all right i bumped this
one up to about 43 miles per hour which
is really fast but the kickoff is slow
to it and we're still modifying it
trying to get as fast as possible
someone's definitely gonna die on this
bike it might be caught on film right
now because i'm gonna go to the top of
that hill i'm gonna open it up and
you'll see how fast this one goes
he's like no
no way dude he supercharged that
no freaking way did you guys hear what
he just said
no way dude so aroused right now that
was sick did you hear what keem said
right then
it's so impressive bro
let's see the supercharged game
just in case i gotta take over drama
alert ladies and gentlemen unfortunately
this evening team tried to open up the
mini bike at 43 miles per hour and this
happened
[Laughter]
there is no dog there's no dog and also
he's in the street
yeah well he said it this one goes like
50 miles an hour but why is fousey
screaming about a dog there's clearly no
dog
wait let's watch that again
i mean keemstar is looking back at
something though in history because he's
probably hearing that and thinking he's
like well there's a dog after me yeah
i'm surprised keem didn't go and hit it
that's why he was looking back he's like
oh [ __ ] i missed one yeah i gotta run
that thing over man
oh okay i saw the dog
i i see the dog there is a dog
we need to we need to make a retraction
where's the it's on the other side of
the road
oh
is it chasing him not really he looks
like he's walking the opposite direction
yeah it's just kind of there he's
definitely not
the dog is going the opposite direction
look at this he's walking away from
kibstar
unbelievable
also watch out fast you have to really
strain your eyes
damn that was probably 20 miles per hour
yeah
it was super fast we got chased by the
dog
yep that was there was no dog
it wasn't that fast there's no dog it
wasn't that fast and it wasn't hilarious
you know what's crazy dude i was in my
car today and i was driving like 65.
that was going so fast
it's crazy people were like whoa look at
that guy so freaking fast
yeah you guys don't probably believe me
huh
it's a stretch that's for sure
yeah dude
all right so y'all saw keem got me that
faze murakami jersey which i appreciate
so freaking much i told him i was gonna
bring something for his bar it's a one
of one cause there's only one left so
let's see queer i can't believe i'm
gonna be given this [ __ ] it's my old
teeth
[Laughter]
one of one you can't come here
get in the actual
uzi but look what it says here like this
was the actual one
wait is that one fusion fought that guy
and like nearly died
man
you can't even show the fight because
it's so graphic but
it is
it's incredible the fusion fought this
one other youtuber
and he refused to put his hands up to
defend himself and the announcers were
like oh my god [ __ ] put up your hands
this is just can we get pull the audio
at least because the even the audio is
just incredible
can somebody find that and send in
discord yeah it's hard for me to we
gotta listen to the audio as he presents
the gloves
all right this is uh like this is part
of youtube history so it's not there was
like barely anyone watching it it looked
like
an abandoned warehouse with uh
party challenge chairs you know fold out
chairs
my discord isn't working so dan if you
could pull it up i guess oh
it's not working it's just blank like i
see the message is popping up on the
right
but it oh there it goes okay
is this at the time stamp
yeah i said just timestamps
yeah this is crazy though
this is crazy by the way too
wait hold on on that audio
yeah look at this this is crazy what
keemstar does on sundays he goes so fast
bro
he tears up the playground this kid hits
a max of like four miles per hour and
keemstar smokes him bro he goes like six
he laughed him the last weekend
yeah
also you've noticed keemstar doesn't
have training wheels so whatever whoa
he's only got two wheels whatever bro
it's just whatever i took the training
wheels off last year bro it's whatever
all right play the audio as king as the
uh
uh
yeah i mean
can we not show those
it's really violent
it's so bloody it's just he's getting
over eyes
[Music]
huh keep going there's a part where he's
like fousey put your hands up for
christ's sake
well time stamping baby find the good
part yeah i'm gonna watch the whole
thing
this was that where do we go
sorry i'm here i'm looking everywhere
for that damn t-shirt why'd you
disappear like that don't do that to me
you're so scared you're on the panel i'm
right here
yeah if you could if somebody could
timestamp the good part where they're
like lucy for god's sake put your hands
up
i did
okay so just play it let it play dan i
mean
from where the time stamp is okay he
says
exactly
trust me it gets better and
all better this is a like this is part
of youtube
so it matters for your bar
this is the actual
no
he's just way to look after himself
trust me it's good
[Music]
no no there's like
you're saying there's another there's
one where it's just it's a bloodbath
towards the end towards the very end of
the fight
it's just you've got to hear it
yeah
this is the original audio
stop somebody find the place i want i i
can't do it live somebody listen we got
a whole council of people find the spot
i want thank you
maybe still looking for the shirt
jesus christ i know for sure that he had
it because i tweeted we both tweeted
about it
this whole house is for youtubers to
come visit and it's like i need [ __ ]
like this in the bar like yeah that's
fousey's glove that's the love that's
the glove great gift great i put thought
into that
[Music]
this glove by the way if you've seen the
fight it's practically brand new
never hit or blocked a single punch
basically
unused yeah
you turn it up a little bit on youtube
oh yeah never turned all the way down
oh yeah i'll turn it up all the way
everything came around full circle y'all
right there on king's bar all right guys
i know you think i'm fixated
i'm just telling you it's worth it
abe gave me a hyperlink
oh abs rolling the dice in the third
round
[Music]
he cannot maintain this he cannot
maintain this level of fighting
let's
i wish you guys could see the footage
man
all right nobody cares it's so funny
his punches
i know just stop just cancel this part
just erase it from your mind
[Laughter]
so
frustrating so frustrating
now i hear you're leaving wednesday i
think so what date is that
oh my god i know you're gonna say i
think it's the day before no you gotta
be here for july 15th
this piece pieces hey and look to all
you youtube boxers who just boxed in 16
ounce gloves and everything i went four
rounds and getting my ass to be what
number does that say
12 ounces 12 ounces to the face four
rounds didn't defend myself me and i
could take a punch your nose couldn't
though
but if you want oh by the way he got so
messed up he had to get like facial
reconstruction surgery
he's
i went 12 rounds not defending myself
what's up i could take a punch and wind
up in the hospital
he did
he really did he was like homer simpson
against mike tyson right yeah yeah yeah
very bad vibes
you know i got another one another what
atv
now it's pretty much y'all i tried to
tell keem do not let me get behind the
wheel
he insists and says you gotta get in you
all know what happens when you're behind
the wheel
yo
look at that thing dude
damn
no way
wow insane
[Music]
wait there's like a little screen at the
top of the
that's crazy that's what his face looked
like yo what's that video at the top can
they see that or is that just for me
just for you okay
[Music]
[Applause]
no freaking way dude
[Music]
no way they're gonna hit a bottle
let's go
no way that was nothing
all right
i don't i mean listen listen
i could watch these guys atv oh somebody
flipped okay i'm in it
[Laughter]
[Music]
eric you okay
i could watch these guys atv all day but
uh
i'm sure there's something more to this
video right
yeah
they spent a good uh 10 to 15 minutes
trying to dig it out of the mud so yeah
we can probably skip all that that's the
climax of the movie you might say
but there's they're like leading up to
their boxes
look like butt monsters
good let's go let's go all right y'all
going scooting again scooting with a
button with my bff right there more atv
bro we get it
that's all i've been doing this is this
this is not a movie
this is a modern day bro
no that's how i lost all the way keto is
the thing yo what is this pizza yo and
now so that was it really exciting now
we're gonna head on down to circle k and
get some snacks probably some beef jerky
some cheese some honey or maybe are you
hungry for dinner bro
[Music]
i was thinking we could eat some
starburst
some honey roasted peanuts
some slim jams
all right i'll get you two slim jims
don't be greedy bro
good
i'm getting the bacon french dip
oh my god kim's are such a degenerate
now i'm not a healthy eater but damn i
don't at least my diet doesn't consist
of corner store grocery [ __ ]
canned goods
i mean he's got money he couldn't afford
better food than that
he's probably still at the house right
yo you want one of these uh bean canned
bean dips fousey for dinner
yo i went to the steakhouse to get some
dinner for us oh sick what'd you get
yo i got sides of bean dip that they
sell
i didn't get anything else
it's got bean dip bro it's hella good
i'm not gonna get it no we already ate
[Music]
how the hell did y'all save me some
mcdonald's
why are they so cheap
i get the vibe that they're both so like
brutally cheap and i'm the cheap one
keemstar makes all these jokes i i'll
tell you you say something about me i'd
get fussy more dinner than a bean than
some cornstarch some [ __ ] cracker
jacks or something he's like that didn't
even buy me a water can't crack your
jacks
oh man
yeah this is super compelling though now
they're in the parking lot of the gas
station let's see what happens
keto guido does chip chip and jerky
oh my god bro
that is not a meal
and take it from me
this is his weight loss program
cheese and jerky holy crap dude
it's a mcdonald's i gotta see that again
jeez piece
didn't get my water into gatorade
well that's what a keto guido does chip
chip and jerky
okay you know
what he's white trash officially
that's the most filed thing i've ever
seen
a little bit of
a little bit of it on his lip there
nice and nice and sloppy
it's such a match out exactly that's
like what i would imagine eating as like
a 12 year old when i grow up i'm just
going to eat slim jims
and cheese dip
[ __ ] you mom
and i'm gonna write i'm gonna write atvs
everywhere
when i can do whatever i want
and i'm gonna build a bar in my basement
oh can we go to a drive-through
no hell no
[ __ ] come on
i wouldn't write home about it let's go
y'all want some weird [ __ ] out here
yeah i'm gonna go there anyway
oh they got that now they got spicy
chicken sandwiches a chicken
number
dude you could have cut this
all of this
easy cut
the fusi tube movie
okay we're going from the gas station a
little beef jerky eating hanging out in
the parking lot heading through the
drive-through
super high-level [ __ ] wonder what
they're gonna order
oh there's another calamity outside
every day
yo what are they gonna order this is so
compelling give me a number oh uh let me
get a number nine can i get a number
nine with a diet coke
bacon king oh that shot so much
anticipation there he got to the food
station while keemstar's ordering
super cinematic
lots of anticipation here hunger
i mean it's poetic it's a movie
oh a grimace
a smile i can't remember ever getting up
to forty dollars out of
that was not stop whining about money
you he calls me cheap you spent forty
bucks at a drive through
i mean what are you
what are you complaining you
such a cheapo 40 bucks
i can't eat everything we just ordered
in one sitting on my own well how much
do you normally
pay at fast food restaurants
not 40 that's what i'm saying
okay this is real interesting guys
apparently 40 doesn't usually spend that
much
first time
it's really a metaphor for keemstar he's
alone but now he's with people it's an
analogy a lot of emotion that's why he's
still taking it back because he he's
usually just by himself
yeah it it requires more analysis but
yeah
i gotta say this is so [ __ ] fair this
is how love and i have been living at
the drive through life spending 40 bucks
plus you guys dropped 40 bucks
well maybe once or twice but dude i've
never heard of anyone spending that much
at a drive through yo you guys have been
hitting the drive-through and haven't
been recording it yeah why don't you
guys film it put it online caught a
movie well after after lockdown we'll do
it next time we'll get the sequel going
where you guys been what have you guys
been hitting up
pop iced chicken popeyes oh
you see that love got a reply from
popeye
what does that mean nope popeye's
chicken
on twitter they say what did you tweet
what happened
uh i don't remember what i said
does anyone remember you're just like yo
love your chicken
yeah pretty much
uh i said like i i made some joke that i
don't remember you remember i said tell
me what you said
i i actually don't remember you guys
thinking i'm dumb i'm actually dumb
someone please help me don't say that
about yourself
here we go i found it
i said i constantly wait your twitter's
young fika
yeah flynn he made a new one
capstone oh i can't stop thinking about
you
thinking about you too
that's not real careful about here i
gotta cut away what the replies either
he got
i think a bunch of people from peta or
something follows popeyes around twitter
and just post like mauled chickens no
way it applies all the time yeah i kind
of weighed me dude whoa pizza [ __ ]
hates me dude that's intense
yeah
i'm just trying to eat some [ __ ]
spicy chicken dog
i ain't trying to make a giant statement
just trying to eat some shaking
yeah
that's awesome they just stalk pop bites
on twitter yeah it's kind of everything
isn't it
no i don't even think it's that i think
it was a h3 fan to be honest because he
posted
or
an h3 hater bro
yeah exactly the haters are everywhere
dude i'm dodging them like keemstar on
the atv bro you can't get rid of them
i can't go fast enough
yeah they're on their small bikes
all right let's just keep trying to
stomach whatever the [ __ ] this is
all right
fousey you're posting too much
you have to you
see what what do you do every day where
do you post every day every instagram
instagram tech talk tick tock usually
youtube youtube
twitter you know you post them i do post
on twitter but i don't care about that
one as much as the other ones and you're
doing videos for igtv like yeah you
gotta do ig tv real
pictures posts well why are you doing
them every day they make you for their
algorithm
this is really great content
let's go forward a bit though
this is the drive
you're just driving home
you could have made this shorter super
uh computer and then they're gonna
let's analyze it a little bit how much
it's like
cuttable uh how much of this has been
coming i mean we're 26 minutes in i mean
realistically this is this is a 10
minute video all in all right it's 39
minutes this could be an eight minute
video to be honest yeah just enough for
a mid roll so
like significant like three quarters of
it could probably go you're saying nine
tenths
frankly about everyone and they're gonna
one be able to predict the future so
they know exactly what you're gonna do
like whatever he's talking about i don't
care
the italians are coming forward grab the
food
they don't even know what's going on so
let me tell you guys it's day three out
in
the middle of nowhere and today kim and
i are going to make why can't i talk
right now today
you're doing fine bro and i have a big
announcement to make i believe yesterday
or the day before we just announced an
address for a fan meetup that keem
decided yes that's the fan meetup that's
where kimi met the 20 year old girl yep
it was the fan meetup
awesome
he's basically doing a dry run with
fousey of how to impress a 20 year old
oh
yeah
yeah oh poor fruity
yep oh we got some it's just the side
chick we got a new
keemstar tick tock as we're doing this
a young
you just gotta watch it's not his tick
tock but he makes an appearance
okay love
that when you're hanging with your
friends and realize one of them looked
like keemstar what are you doing in my
house
what are you doing in my house i want
waffle fry
i don't get it
what maybe
explain this
go ahead amy your your mic's muted
i apologize because i can't listen to it
oh because of how we have things up
right now i thought she was literally
with keemstar i think i got got
yeah i thought she was in at his house
yeah so the whole point of what you do
is that you're supposed to watch stuff
before you send it to me because i'm
doing a live show so i can't like
preview content to find out if it's good
for the show i watch it but just now
i apologize yeah so so i'm i'm watching
so yeah you're supposed to watch it i'm
leaving
and then make an assessment right
and then hand it to me okay i'm sorry
let's get back to the gold content
yeah just to be clear on the on what
your job is
god bless
to come up with all right scare roy into
the press conference and we're holding a
press conference to make the
announcement boxing promotional company
for all let me just do this again
it's the three year anniversary because
at midnight it's gonna be and we don't
talk about that day hate dies love
arrives stop talking about that day
yo we're going to see drake no dude you
guys are so annoying we're kidding i
just i usually don't read the comments
people get so angry and i like we're
joking with a b
it's crazy how some people get so wild
dude
what did you see i didn't see it just
like bowling
chill amy did his best i mean are you
guys 12
i like genuinely don't understand
how you can take it so seriously
why are you guys small
wait you sh why are you so big
what the [ __ ] is going on
get smaller zach yeah zach why are you
so big what the [ __ ] dude
shrink yourself
alpha dog
zack shrink yourself
i i honestly i don't know [ __ ] how
man get on our level dude i think
they're just slouching dude
[Laughter]
yeah that's better
i'm still like
too big you're too big
you gotta bring it down further yeah you
can go further
you got it scoot back a little bit yeah
there you go
looks great
so i'm assuming this means the content
is really good
everyone's slouched in their chairs
man this is a hell of an episode isn't
it guys
and we love this is the covid special we
go
we're just gonna watch this whole
episode
well it wasn't really a whole episode we
started like an hour we had a lot of
good stuff in the beginning let's not
forget yeah it's a lot less
that's even cooler because on that day
i'm telling you right then and there
hate died and loved the right
dude yeah can we please get to a [ __ ]
point
online
[Music]
redneck land and you're dressed like
that this is him he's going to meet the
20 year old this is kind of epic like
there is somewhere some in a courtroom
somewhere reviewing this footage
possibly
chris hanson is reading
the text messages
right now
okay i'm just going to raise some
eyebrows for the locals just like oh
i can't believe this is captured spark
in their lives
we really haven't prepared the
announcement we're making y'all like
we're fine we're just going to talk dude
i've never had that's always a good idea
kim show's really good off the cuff
when you're doing a press conference
it's best to just go in totally dry
unprepared just wing it
not very different from his uh news uh
show i mean that's how he does drama
alert that's been successful so the life
for anything bro i'll let god
write the script
all right one of the rules screaming oh
i can't wait to see who's there
this is actually exciting
so let's see what kimstar's fans look
like
i didn't tell him to do that poor guy oh
we're doing an announcement right away
oh we're ready
[Applause]
this is exciting
i'm pumped to see what a fan meetup
slash
this is him blasting it out to his whole
town this is a
press conference this is huge for
buffalo yeah
[Music]
wow
let's soak it in what do you guys see
here
what do you see zach
what's so funny bro
what's the problem i'm sorry
man don't bite me
how can i not mind you
just [ __ ] out then
are you left in your house
no no are you just laughing at the crowd
oh who's this who's that on is that
dobrick wait no no no
look
like three people to the left of that
guy wait is that is that the girl
well
[Music]
we're not at like church sundays or
anything y'all can have some fun and get
lit like how y'all doing
cool
first of all thank you guys all for
coming out huge announcement for the 100
people in buffalo listening right now
it's going to change the world forever
yo so i want to tell you that we're
going to be not even in this city in l.a
poorly commentating on boxing i think
it's already dissolved the happy bunch
[ __ ]
i get confused because it seems like
these pop up all the time now with these
like youtube boxing things is this the
one that
he was doing in collaboration with with
triller
i don't know i think this came after
happy punch maybe because he said he was
working with kavanaugh on something
right it was a boxing was it i don't
know if it's happy punch or something
else or whatever he said that he hadn't
announced the name so that's right
unsure
if this is his uh if this is the
crossover
yeah i mean he's as you know he has got
a lot of experience in commentating
boxing so
he's perfectly qualified great job yeah
did a great job boxing thing has been
taken off and me and fousey we did a duo
on the last boxing event youtubers
versus tick tockers the thing blew up
we're high in demand right now so we
decided no one thing was a huge
financial disaster it was it was a giant
scam
they sold no tickets
and let's be honest you guys are not in
demand i have not seen you back
the only person in demand is kavanaugh
because he just wants to piss me off
let's be honest right and i haven't seen
you doing anything by the way about that
either
huge demand
well actually fousey had a brilliant
idea and he's about to tell you what it
is oh you're gonna pass it like that
it's your idea
so as you guys know in the years that
we've watched boxing on tv you've had
showtime sports you've had hbo you've
had the ufc and you've had different
promotional companies who have carried
these events so basically what me and
keem are here to do is to give life and
new life these people are just there for
the spectacle because like what is who
cares bro
like you're not you're just announcing
that you and kim are going to be like
commenting i mean why why does anyone
care look at this look at the excitement
hold on look at the excitement dude
dude these guys are definitely haters
these guys are h3 fans for sure
look at this [ __ ] eating grins here they
can't believe what they're seeing dude
these guys are i would say 50 of these
people are h3 fans
team are here to do is to give life and
new light to the boxing and social media
scene so we are launching our own
promotional company called happy punch
promotions no way
[Applause]
and with happy punch promotions we're
going to give you a new look into
boxing a new look
i love that they didn't prep for this at
all yeah
laundering
we're launching a new company no no need
to like think about it we're gonna talk
about boxing
we're gonna breathe new light into
boxing
and ride atvs bro
also i don't
i haven't been to i don't know i haven't
been to buffalo uh but
this
venue that they're at does it not just
seem like it's just somebody's backyard
it does have a weird vibe it looks like
i mean i don't know what yeah i don't
know what's the vibe in buffalo right
that's the thing i think this is the
vibe in buffalo
it's butcher's house down the street
this is where he got the jerky his
childhood butcher yeah
that's what he called him
his childhood butcher what does that
mean he did his uh he deserves his
circumcision
[Laughter]
ufc a new look into anything involving
fighting through our eyes and our
personalities to really bring a new age
and resurgence what boxing is in today's
day and age so thank you all for coming
out people are saying that uh booboo
bennett is in the crowd it was booboo
ben
caitlyn bennett the uh oh the gun girl
girl wait how did you see her oh i
didn't i'm just saying there's a bunch
of people in the chat saying she's out
there
oh it that just kind of looks like her i
don't think she's an h3 fan all those
guys are
yeah maybe this is the weirdest video
like why does any people any of these
people care
that you're doing boxing promo it's just
so weird look it's like a wooden fence
outside how is this not about oh yeah
that's a dude's house
but there's warmers and a patio i don't
know
buffalo do it different
i think
[Applause]
dude this is pretty epic this is like a
good time man you know
looks like fun
[Applause]
oh this is this is fousey's song i think
you only got drip yeah i think so
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
does it sound like was he sure i don't
want it to be copyright i i think he he
had a backup singer i i think this is an
influencer song um
this is probably cool to play well they
played it
yeah
i'll just mute it
i'm pretty sure that's a fousey song
though look up a foosie song
oh such a shame i wanna hear it
i hated the man there he is i knew it
ah i knew it listen a dollar dream i'm a
dreamer the role he told me
i got me
this guy is definitely an h3 fan bro
with the tiger woods the tiger wedge diy
shirt
that's your rips kind of
oh no that's hype dude yeah that is hype
my button the actually start i bring the
top in the wood i ain't coughing oh that
was her that's her
that's her
that's kim's 20 year old girlfriend dude
that's definitely her yeah i think so
that's where it all started yep
just picking up on
kids at a fan meetup straight to the
atvs what's up girl
there we go you come to the student's
backyard often
it is not [ __ ] fair
in a mud puddle
yo you ever mudded you a mudder
kim starts wearing full sin merch by the
way
sick
just to tie it all together wow this is
the legion of doom it's like
the nail guys keem
ryan cavanaugh like they're forming an
enclave we're really telling you i bring
i bring together i've always brought
together axises of evil against me
people are saying no braces not that
girl the the first no this was the first
one that he had like a really this was
the girl who was on the aid and roster
correct right who he was said he was
like in love with her and [ __ ] and then
she dumped him after the adam ross
stream yeah this isn't his assistant
yeah we're not talking about the new
girl i see a bunch of people saying that
not the braces girl this is the one that
was in the first one yeah
his the first of many
uh
confirm it no this i'm telling you this
is her he said that he met her at a fan
meeting pull up the picture of him in
the pool with the hat jersey
you'll see it's her there's no somebody
have that on hand
i'll look for it yeah it's kind of hard
to see another discord
what the hell that filter so good love
did what oh
[ __ ] that's crazy you look like kids say
the darndest things right now
yeah i actually think i recognize her
from my class
[Laughter]
you guys have lunch together how are you
it's the true young figure what's so
cute
i'm 100 sure that's her someone got that
photo between your legs
yeah
i've seen her without the glasses and
stuff but
that is definitely her
shout out to keemstar in the pool with
the hat and jersey
never forgetty
yeah this is history in the making guys
pretty awesome
yeah as you know all
keemstar is about 38 he has a fan meetup
and uh
he he goes to a fan meetup and he meets
20 year old or even younger 19 year old
girls
that's so sick so epic that's so sick
you guys
that's not creepy at air at all right
alpha behavior
that's not creepy at all is it
that's definitely her sorry to say
and this is when she realized i can't do
this anymore they broke up like the next
day yeah
history in the making
i'm glad we watched oh now there's
there's keemstar's fans
this makes sense this is drama alert
phantom right here
so he did a full performance on stage of
this [ __ ] that's pretty wild
sorry
[Music]
yeah i think it's made for people around
your age group
play that [ __ ] again dog yeah recess
turn up to this song
yo you ever listen to this while having
cheese uh the cheez-its or no what do
you what would you call those things
with the red stick and you spread the
cheese on the cracker
yeah uh ritz something weren't there
was it a lunchable just a lunchable yeah
sick i love lunch
hell yeah brother
yo do you ever listen to [ __ ] while
doing lunchables it's fire bro
my mom is not around
that is the best filter it's really of
all time holy crap
[Music]
yo i've been to like arby's with more
people
just saying
oh wait was that fousey
hang on this is more possibly more
oh no it's not
sign my g fuel i don't think you're
sponsored by them bro
i don't think that's an appropriate
thing to do how'd that happen why are
you signing cheap fuel bottles you have
no affiliation with them
[Music]
what wasn't that kid cudi yeah that was
kid see ghosts why the
[ __ ]
you guys are just taking credit for
everything oh bring me a book of
shakespeare
the bible
say the bible rembrandt
i'll sign it
[Laughter]
why are you signing other people's
albums
[Music]
yo
bro literally
this looks off the chain bro i see more
people in and out at 9 00 pm
[Laughter]
turning the [ __ ] up right now dude
in kevin's backyard
what the [ __ ] man
my boy kevin has a nice backyard for
this press conference
[Laughter]
yeah he's got umbrellas and [ __ ]
it's fire
[Music]
i need a dream
i can't hear i can't listen to this yeah
here i'll mute it yeah
[Music]
mother out what is wrong with this hat
it's like two sides wait did we see a
atlas keemstar
pack it up
back it up
back it up
nope oh he's built forward oh he's smart
slick close yeah
plus might be worth screenshotting
man i have an update
you got the shirt up there story
redemption story
indeed i demand a public apology i never
apologize i never said you were lying i
never said tick tock was real
here's another tick tock from the same
user oh okay keemstar did reply and he
said that place looks familiar
okay let's see
so this has 60 likes dude okay
wait that's keemstar's basement yeah i
mean that does look like it that's it
the place looks familiar says keemstar
wait his roof is all clouded up like
that
he's got like yeah the sistine's the
chapel oh yeah he can't wait this from
this is from december yeah right around
the same time holy crap you think yeah
december 16th when was this announcement
yo
when was this possible after this fan
meet up yo when did he post that video
hold on
august
yeah you think he id'd her
oh this one came out all the way back in
august okay you think he id her dan to
get in the bar
uh
yeah i'm sure he follows all the
regulations
uh
in his house that the front door is
barricaded in the middle of nowhere
hazard you know
dude what the hell
what this is interesting maybe we could
find our age
well wait so can we watch the the first
one that we all roasted him for now with
the context of understanding okay send
that one back
can you research this girl and see if
you can find her ajb without me i don't
want to like show too much of her
content
so here is
here is the original one that you sent
me
it says keemstar back at it again when
you're hanging with your friends you
realize one of them looks like keemstar
what are you doing in my house
what are you doing in my house i want
waffle fry i'm still confused
what are you confused over so there to
get there actually together
yeah yeah okay
they're in the uh
they're okay so you're right they're in
the dungeon you had it right
i apologize
wow okay the chat needs to apologize to
me too because they were no they were
mad at me
no a lot of them were making fun of me
we all there's a collective apology a
lot of them were making well there's a
collective apology to a b at this moment
redemption story it's okay i know how to
do my job okay whoa
we got the glasses can you do something
to see what's that girl's age see yeah
i'm on her instagram right now i'm
looking
it's awesome right hey ian
okay i thought he was asleep
looks dead
i think his eyes were closed
yeah he's trying to do stick he doesn't
want to participate in the class
they weren't closed they weren't closed
dan's trying to set me up
i've never done such a thing wait what
does that mean giving you a little
giving you a little poke making sure you
were awake
i don't know what's going on
we can't see by the way
oh it's really small during the whole
show we can't see it where we said dan
goes well that's your [ __ ] problem
well to be honest the count well we had
to choose between
them being able to see are you guys
seeing the council i personally think
the council is awesome the council is
awesome i think i think the fan base has
been enjoying the council right
yeah
can i just point something out i don't
know if anyone's pointing this out above
ian it says deliver happiness
yeah
that's just been cracking me up the
whole show can we is it possible to
customize this console i want to make
some custom consoles for the for the pod
it was just built into the [ __ ] zoom
application is it funny because ian does
not look happy
yes
yeah
yeah we can make a
custom uh council room that'd be great
i want everybody to put on that baby
filter that loves rocking it's so good
this is the only one i got oh how do we
oh yours is kind of scary
still has a beard well it looks really
oh yeah without the beard it looks
really good oh you're oh
hey how you doing girl i like this one
talk to me baby okay
hey cam how you doing talk to me baby
ian wants you guys to see what their
screen looks like this is this this is
what they see yeah that's how we're
watching the show
i mean yeah fair enough that's fair
enough
but the council is awesome so
fair enough
dude what is wrong with this hat it's
like two sizes too small i need my
normal hat look hey the meet and greet
was fire but we may have pulled off the
worst press conference of all time
a moment you call that a moment of
clarity
that's what alcoholics call a moment of
clarity
yeah no no and we're the ones who talk
[ __ ] about the ones that happen
yeah true true true true that's all you
gonna say
oh we're filming yeah in the bathroom
yeah let's go you know all about that
how about that that's where you film all
your content stop
team's been dying to get a drink ever
since we got here
looks like things are going great hey
what's up man don't record this this
team just getting his shot
yet you still included it
that whole bathroom scene
keem getting a shot
you kept it in
why
why god what is going on outside
it's like freaking
maybe the war broke out
world war three we're at war with with
russia vladimir
welcome americans we are entering los
angeles
do not panic
the red alert theme song
i'm recording taking some shots the
latino tick
keep an eye out
[Music]
[Applause]
it really looked like he was just
talking to that guy
awesome he's like yo is this guy going
to stop
just trying to chill at kevin's
room
yeah i don't care
we don't care
we don't care
that was really good
we don't care by the way this place is a
bar it looks like i guess buffalo just
do it different man that's buffalo stuff
you can zone a shed apparently to uh get
an alcohol license in buffalo
million dollars to whoop that
[ __ ]
i will get in the ring with one person
on this planet ethan
million dollars to whoop that
[ __ ]
do you think after you box him the beef
will be settled after that because
that's my next point
i will wait until his child is 18 years
old and i am 65 and i'll whoop his
[ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah i'll [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yeah i'm going to beat up a child
yo i fantasize about kicking you about
kicking ethan's kid's ass bro
keemstar
[Laughter]
he actually offered me three million
dollars to get in the ring with him did
he really yeah
[ __ ]
do it
no i was like bro i'm not going to
validate you
not happening that's three million three
million dollars
yeah keemstar would default turned into
a whole social club's thing
uh we have some exclusive behind the
scenes
of um of the cameraman's fan
what is this got leaked
you want to unpack this for me cameron
they're just bullying spin all this
he's a professional though he keeps the
camera up and rolling he's a
professional we love we love that
yeah
[Music]
you're still recording where you are now
don't give us a friend
speaker i will not give a shout out to
keemstar on stage
he knows
more notes
wow he really i mean i don't have
beautiful handwriting but
this is like learning to stay in the
lions [ __ ]
hey thanks for the advice man i wish i
had more time to talk with you but man
you are a huge ins
wait this isn't from keemstar is it
that's the implication it can't get
better than that hey thanks for the
advice man i wish i had more time to
talk with you but man you are the
handwritten inspiration that they took a
picture of his reading on his phone
let's be honest he wrote that himself do
you think he wrote that yeah
wait and then he censored
the word [ __ ] yeah but it wasn't
censored a second ago we just saw it
wait we did
it's awesome
for real
yeah what a dumbass the editing is so
good on this [ __ ] it's so good it can't
get better than that hey fusi thanks for
the advice man i wish i had more time to
talk with you but man you are a huge
inspiration to me i want to impact
people in a positive way just like you
it's just so hard to stay motivated man
especially when you don't see results
even after years of work can't wait to
read your book the kid with curly hair
that's though that's what's happening
you don't understand people out here are
real
wow
oh dude we couldn't have asked for
anything better no that went amazing i'm
not gonna lie yo look i'm not really
yeah wife why fousey in the back like
he's in an uber though
uh it's better for the camera man
actually because then he can get shots
of both of them
if the cameraman's in the back it's a
little bit more awkward i'm giving him
the benefits driving miss daisy up for
real religious but i did pray to god to
make sure this worked out
and this really worked out team was
tripping
ball sacks before we went out i was
we got a big one for you today much
bigger than we originally thought we are
happy to announce that we have signed
our first fighter to happy punch
promotions set him up with youtuber
after youtuber tick tocker versus tick
tocker we have the one the only
oh so i remember they they announced it
it was just some random like no name
yeah i think it's already gone i think
it's fizzled out
yeah i mean nothing
they haven't had a fight right
like that's the whole point of a boxing
promoting company is to create a fight
did you find any intel on that girl
maybe no i can't find her age but i do
believe she's the same girl that went uh
that was hanging out recently with them
um i just sent a picture right now
friends with his current uh
assistant yeah
wait do you think that's her to be the
same girl oh yeah
so about between 17 and 19 you know
she's she's definitely super young i
mean
yeah
dude he's so cool i [ __ ] up
so cool
he's so cool
some people like to relive their high
school years
keemstar wants to uh
what's the way to put that
yeah keemstar wants to amen you know
i'm a little scared of where yeah
some people miss high school
well keemstar uh
whatever some people want a second
chance at high school
[Music]
or third or fourth
that's what i was kind of thinking yeah
love said he wants to live inside of a
high schooler and
that's kind of that's kind of where i
was going but i wasn't sure if it was
it was when we arrived
yeah
i just don't understand how people are
friends with him like faze banks
aiden ross like how can you openly
associate with keemstar the man
literally picks up girls outside of high
schools
well
well until a few years ago he had some
clout and purchase on youtube i feel
like that has faded over the last three
to four years but but they're still the
same people are friends with
well them make a lot of money together i
don't know i mean you think so yeah the
phase thing
i mean do we i don't think it's publicly
known but
i've always assumed that keem has some
stake in phase in some way or another
oh i don't think i don't know i don't
think so
no
it's just not like it's not like
majority or anything but
well maybe it doesn't
yeah
okay maybe i'm not saying no but i don't
think so i think he would have fluxed
that if he was hmm yeah
well anyway pretty exciting stuff what
do you guys think well yeah totally
unnecessary what's your rating where are
you for the for the for the movie the
movie i mean i'd give it probably like a
1.2 1.2 out of 10. yeah
a little something
i mean this it sounded good
i liked it was decent yeah i like the
origin story of meeting the 20 year old
yeah
it sagged a bit i think it could have
used more editing yeah the second act it
kind of dragged
the second act yeah definitely dragged
agreed yeah yeah
can we all agree on that sven was the
mvp in this sam is definitely the mvp
and honestly i want justice for sven
because he was being bullied just his
first fan yeah honestly justice
yep
shout out to kevin who hosted that in
his backyard good guy
big meat
people are loving it though and the
man fussy showing that fan love he
hearted every [ __ ] comment
which usually is nice but looks a little
desperate in this case
like zero [ __ ] like comment
dude there's no way he read those right
no he just went through look at he liked
every single [ __ ] comment
that's intense it's pretty intense
every comment
look at this
i'm still scrolling
every comment
everyone
jesus so many
dude
wait i want to find out
if he went through that much he probably
also deleted all the negative ones so i
was wondering i was going to try to find
a negative one see if he hearted it
yeah
i think love is right that's a good
point
dude
maybe sort by latest or newest
dude look at all these likes
i mean is there a difference between
showing the fans to love and
this
holy crap dude
you saw a negative one
cam sent something about his chewing
oh for real yeah wait how'd you find it
says uh
these aren't hearted though how did you
find these
youtube back
searchers
with your mouth closed jesus
brought you with your mouth closed
[ __ ] mouth open chewing
fussy chilling so annoying
oh my god the cena foosey tree was
horrible
i just dropped a hearted negative one
okay hearted negative one
so i think that this is proof that he
just masshearted the way
choosey
juicy
the way fousey chews i swear to god he
hearted it
ain't no way he read that [ __ ] boy right
no
no
why would he heart that because it's
verified account
bro he's like dude he just he mass
hearted this i'm still i'm on like page
100.
if there would be anyone who would go
through all these comments wouldn't it
be foosy though yeah it's just too much
time you gotta have better stuff to do
yeah you have to have better stuff to do
this is like an hour of at least or
maybe even more
i mean look at this all the way down bro
this is insane
[Laughter]
why would he heart this how good does
drama alert pay heart
love that
why would he hurt that
a time stamp left my uh
he how did this love what you're doing
but i feel happy punch is a copy of
happy dad from now great video heart
why would he hurt that
yeah that's a bit suspicious
we should
wait look at this i thought fousey being
a muslim couldn't eat beef jerky heart
why would you heart that
it shouldn't make any sense for you to
hurt that comment
the whole thing is eating not only that
but he's eating cheese and meat together
i think arabs can do that no oh is that
only jews that don't do that oh hell
yeah we could do that yeah it's just the
jews the jews that it's bro the the
heirs they know how to get down with
cheese and meat yeah i don't know why
the jews [ __ ] that one up i'm kosher
i'm actually having a big kick out of
going and seeing what comments you are
this thing is like when you heart a
comment it's supposed to be meaningful
and special but when you're hardening
random [ __ ] like this it doesn't mean it
means you didn't read them when is your
book coming out heart
it means you didn't read them look at
the one i just dropped in discord
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's so [ __ ] funny
holy [ __ ] you guys
this
this is my favorite part
holy crap
did [ __ ] try that bacon french dip
heart
oh my god
this is so funny
why is [ __ ] acting like he's never done
any of this stuff before he's done all
this and more with roman art
oh
this is great
life is definitely way cheaper in
buffalo
oh yeah dude
uh am i the one bro am i the only one
annoyed at fousey chilling with his
mouth open heart
[ __ ] chewing with his mouth open heart
there you go now this is good ah this is
where keemstar met his new girlfriend
heart
is so funny
this is the best thing ever
i love cringe
cringe hearts
fussy chew with your mouth open dude
heart
chew that cheese with your mouth closed
man
heart
oh my god listen to fousey chew his
horrible heart
oh this is the best dude
sorry for everyone who's thinking i'm
i'm just so entertained by this
you forgot to show gamestar's bar
i think that's ironic right it's from 44
minutes ago it's it's
okay
so that's why it doesn't have a heart i
was like yo this one doesn't work he'll
get on it
oh yeah he'll start liking all your guys
let's look at let's start by knew and
see if uh i bet he's making sven do all
this
yes that's what i had the same thought i
wonder if he's making someone else do
this that's a lot look how far up i'm
scrolling it's all hearts dude what the
hell
holy crap
you you know for sure he didn't read any
of them
cringe so yeah okay
we'll see if oh
this whole look at this one
this one
this whole video is gross heart
[Laughter]
this whole video is gross
heart
oh
this is the best [ __ ] ever
the chat are saying it's 14 pages
14 pages of hearts
i don't know if ian's just doing schtick
right now but he's straight dozing off
dude
he's delivering happiness
i was reading comments on my phone
because i can't
see you're reading comments under your
eyelids
oh
so funny
i want to punch fousey for the way he
eats heart
that's keem girls that that's keem's new
girl at 23 heart
oh
keemstar is such a tool i can't stand
the prick heart
yo so this is the keemstar he'll lose
his mind
he'll think that it's a whole big
conspiracy oh the fousey [ __ ] hates
it yes oh that's a good idea
yo somebody straight somebody
guys send us the game and be like yo why
is fousey liking these comments about
you
gives us such a tool can't stand the
heart
straight up hearted that [ __ ] keem was
wrecked at the end yeah
so at the end of that video that's them
driving back from the uh
from the bar right
wait yeah drunk driving was he straight
up drunk driving in that
i didn't even think about that but yeah
rick and rickless
they're on camera wet and reckless
he's falling in the footsteps of his
hero ryan
imagine when these guys both turn 50
both terrible people hard
little sus with happy dad just dropping
heart
oh my god this is the best thing ever
keem [ __ ] will stink oh he didn't like
that one damn
yeah some guys send that comment to to
keem
fousey really backstabbed need a new
camera guy heart oh poor spend
wait
a little bit further down wait what was
wrong with the camera guy he's the only
one who kept it all together i agree
why are they [ __ ]
need a new camera guy you harded that
bro send that to sven right now
that is dirty
oh
so so we're not going to address the
fact that keem anarchy wears three inch
denim shorts she dresses like it's from
2014
heart
hard to buy fizzy
love that grab that one too
make sure keem nice
oh [ __ ] all right that's enough of that
good [ __ ] huh yep
oh i did skip that one the slapping of
the gums was so [ __ ] annoying yeah he
skipped no heart
he read that one
um
i gotta find one more good one i just
can't
close your damn mouth when you're eating
dog heart
all right that's enough cringe heart i
just love that
all right well that's enough guys that's
enough
fun times huh yeah
i wear shorts i don't wear jords you
guys understand that's a huge [ __ ]
difference
people go well you wear shorts too
not shorts yeah there's nothing wrong
with shorts inherently
is it raining
it might be it was raining this morning
all right well i'm going back into um
isolation isolation and we'll be back on
friday probably for another council of
the rex
episode that's right maybe we can figure
out a way so they can actually see what
we're doing yeah we can figure something
out
we did this on the fly it was a last
minute day love the council of the rix
though this was a huge development for
us
so back on friday we're going to do a
wendy williams immemorial
and it's going to be a fun show
maybe we shouldn't call it immemorial
her show died not her i know but
she
she could be on the way off on the way
out and then maybe it's a little awkward
it would be awkward hey do you know what
you know what wendy williams death
rattle will sound like
oh no
play it zach
i think i think it'll actually be that
i'm gonna miss her man i genuinely
clap genuinely love wendy
i'm sad that to see her go man really
yeah that is a loss
that is the loss
all right well we'll see you guys on
friday have a great day have a great
thursday and uh stay good and stay
blessed all right guys thanks for
watching
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
sleep
[Music]
you